want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel is created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only andrew hueberman
for any of us success in any endeavor is
very closely related to how much focus
we can bring to that endeavor
and the reward system you start to
realize is entirely internal no one's
coming along and cramming dopamine in
your ear or dripping it in your brain
it's all internal and this starts to
bring us into the kind of like
discussion around mindsets because so my
colleague carol dweck who you know
popularized this growth mindset
it's again a very misunderstood concept
it's the idea that we can change so
that's built into that but the discovery
of growth mindset was of these kids that
actually really enjoyed doing problem
sets that they knew they couldn't get
right but for them they would get this
like dopamine release from just focusing
on the problem they like doing puzzles
they couldn't get right it sounds crazy
but inevitably those kids are very good
at puzzles and very good at math and on
these kinds of things so growth mindset
is i believe sort of a
neuroscience lens on growth mindset
would be that the agitation and stress
that you feel at the beginning of
something and when you're trying to lean
into it and you can't focus is just a
recognized gait you have to pass that
through that gate to get to the focus
component and then if you can reward the
effort process you really start to feel
joy
and low levels of excitement in the
effort process that's that buffering of
adrenaline that's that feeling like yes
i've got a lot of adrenaline in my
system but i'm on the right path
it feels good to walk up this hill so to
speak
and when you start to bring those neural
circuits together
you really start to create a whole set
of circuits that are designed to be
exported to any behavior you want
so if it's writing a book great if it's
podcasting great if it's building a
business great if it's if it's
you know building a terrific
relationship great then the circuits
that mother nature has designed are
incredibly generic so that we could
adapt to whatever it is that we need to
do and i think the misunderstanding
around how these circuits work has led
to this idea that there's some secret
entry point maybe marked flow on the
door and there's a trampoline up to that
door and you just open that door and
you're gonna be in it right and nothing
could be further from the truth and
anyone who's done well in any career or
athletic pursuit knows this
but unfortunately there's a kind of
obsession with the idea that it's all
supposed to feel good and it does feel
good but there's a whole staircase in
which it feels kind of lousy we can be
driven from a place of anger frustration
and and you know revenge or we can be
driven from a place of you know love
gratitude and etc i i'm not here to
judge which one is better or worse but
the nervous system doesn't distinguish
between them so if you're the kind of
person that needs to you know kind of
budge yourself into something great if
you're the kind of person that wants to
do things from more of a warm fuzzy
feeling that's fine too what i will say
is this the ability to tap into this
dopamine reward system which
is activated anytime you're in pursuit
of something that's outside the
boundaries of your skin and literally
the boundaries of your body as well as
the reward system the serotonin oxytocin
system which is really about the things
that are contained within your own body
and immediate experience things like
gratitude and you know
touch and comfort and things like that
with loved ones
the ability to tap into both is crucial
now you said something really important
which was well negative thoughts
negative thoughts what to do i don't
believe that it's very easy to suppress
negative thoughts however when you
realize that thoughts can be
deliberately introduced you can start
replacing negative thoughts with new
types of thoughts so you can always add
something in but when people start to
realize that thoughts are very much like
physical actions of reaching and picking
up a glass of water or taking a jog
around the ball block or typing an email
perfectly this is something i sometimes
do because i'm i you know i struggle to
do the perfect email not all my emails
are perfect but when i do one i make
sure that i i complete and i think okay
it's possible it's not because the email
being perfect is so important it's
because i want to remind myself that my
thoughts and my actions are essentially
the same the nervous system can organize
thoughts so for somebody that's
struggling
you know we have these examples like oh
they were really back on their heels or
they were so depleted no money and all
this stuff what are they gonna we have
so many examples like that but in trying
to make it actionable it's really about
saying yep that's all true
but i'm going to introduce a thought
which is i made it through today
i'm
i made it through today and that's
actually worth celebrating at a micro
level so if you can give yourself
dopamine rewards in small increments
right you're not trying to celebrate
that you made it through one day
sometimes that's a huge feat but most of
the time you just want to dose yourself
with a little bit of that internal
release of dopamine
you start rewarding incremental steps
and if there's anything that your
listeners could take away from this
whole thing about dopamine and reward
schedules and being in movement it's
reward incremental steps
in particular
incremental steps that are about forward
action so maybe that's writing an email
maybe that's
um maybe that's that run around the
block maybe that's something much
grander for you as you get better at
things right the stairs get further and
further away from one another because
you've achieved more success and so they
tend to be you have to take the rungs on
the ladder further apart so to speak
that's a time when you really need to
implement not only the dopamine rewards
but also those serotonin and oxytocin
rewards etc so to make it actionable i
would say remember don't spend so much
time trying to suppress negative
thoughts if you need trauma therapy
pursue that with a professional but if
you have negative thoughts just remember
i can also introduce positive thoughts
the same way i can control running
around the block positive thoughts are
the equivalent of forward physical
action and if you reward them internally
you buffer yourself against the quitting
circuit this norepinephrine circuit we
were talking about before you are
building a stronger version of yourself
completely between your own ears and
some people say well that's silly it's
like you're saying oh i'm going to jump
up and down reward myself for doing
nothing no you're building the neural
circuits that reward that you can
control self-reward and in doing that
you can push through days and weeks of
effort consistently i don't mean
necessarily all-nighters but you can
push and push and push
you know my career is one that was made
over two decades it wasn't we had our
big you know peaks and we had a lot of
valleys but
learning to control these rewards is
absolutely key and i know you've done
this too tom it's like you know it the
huge wins are great in fact there's a
much better way to maintain ongoing
action toward a goal that also involves
visualization
but it turns out it's not about
visualizing success it's about
visualizing failure the balsettus lab
and other labs have looked at whether or
not people make progress toward goals of
different types
whether or not they're thinking about
the goal
they're thinking about that goal line
and what they want to achieve that
long-term goal and all the wonderful
things associated with it or whether or
not they're thinking about all the ways
in which they could fail and root to
that goal
right this is not typically what we are
encouraged to do typically we are told
don't imagine failure push failure out
of your mind only focus on success you
know fake it till you make it or it's a
phrase that i absolutely hate uh frankly
because it's not even clear what that
means and it's not even clear what the
ethical form of that is i think it means
continue despite any anxiety or fear
that things won't work out but if you
look at the literature the scientific
literature
what the balcettis lab and other labs
have shown is that there's a near
doubling near doubling in the
probability of reaching one's goal
if you focus
routinely on
foreshadowing failure you think about
the ways in which things could fail if
you take action a or you take action b
and instead therefore you take action c
you're supposed to think about how
things could fail if you don't get up
and run each morning if your goal is say
a fitness goal so let's use that as an
example because even though i realize
people are in pursuit of many things not
just fitness
fitness goals and physical goals are a
very concrete thing that we can all get
on the same page about
because they're
related to actions let's say somebody
that sets a goal of
running five miles four times a week
minimum and as many as seven four times
a minimum before eight am okay in a
previous podcast on habits i talked
about the benefits of not necessarily
setting specific times that one will do
things but setting time blocks that one
will do things so you say before 8am
you're gonna run five miles
and that's gonna happen up to seven days
a week okay
one version of this would be okay sit
back in a chair and think about how
great you're gonna feel and look if
you're doing this every day how your
health is going to improve how
everything is going through your blood
markers of lipids etc are going to
improve okay fine that's the
visualization goal
of visualizing the end point turns out
that is far less effective and maybe
even counterproductive compared to
thinking about
what's going to happen if you don't do
this
the negative health outcomes that are
going to occur the disappointment you're
going to have in yourself the fact that
you're going to wait until 7 30 that's
not long enough for many people to run
five miles you got to put it on your
shoes it can be pouring rain or even
hailing or snowing outside and now
you're not going outside unless you're
somebody who's particularly motivated to
do that okay so foreshadowing failure
turns out to be the best way to motivate
toward goal pursuit in fact as i
mentioned before there's a near doubling
in the likelihood that people will reach
goals of any kind when they're
constantly thinking about how bad it's
going to be if they fail if we think
back to the neural circuit associated
with assessing value in our goal
pursuits this makes perfect sense the
amygdala that center of the brain that's
involved in anxiety and fear and worry
well the amygdala is one of the four
core components of our goal setting and
goal pursuit circuitry and there's no
bypassing that there is no one listening
to this or watching this whose amygdala
is not involved in their goal-setting
and goal pursuit
behavior and so while i'd love to be
able to tell you that all you should
think about is rainbows and puppies and
all the wonderful rewarding things that
are going to happen when you achieve
your goals the truth is you should be
thinking mainly about how bad it's
really going to get if you don't do it
how disappointing yourself you're going
to feel how
it will negatively impact you if not in
the immediate term in the long term if
indeed your goal is to reach your goal
so
i want to emphasize that i'm not
interested in encouraging people to
flagellate themselves i'm encouraging
people to
achieve their goals and it turns out the
best way to do that is by foreshadowing
failure and the more specific you can
get by writing down or thinking about or
talking about how bad it will be if you
don't achieve your goals the more likely
you are to achieve those goals i really
believe that we all have some superpower
that reflects maybe this is a bit of a
scientific explanation that reflects the
fact that our biology
is tilted in some direction people often
think about their biology being tilted
in a direction that doesn't serve them
like oh you know my parents were this
and my you know or i'm not a good
athlete or um whatever but
it's also tilted in the direction of
something really special so like when i
was a kid
of that age
i was fascinated by animals i was like
my and so
had i learned to listen to that more i
used to hide my interest in animals
because i thought it was kind of not it
wasn't cool like i didn't play the
guitar in college i didn't surf i always
like like i can tell you all these facts
about mustelids and ferrets like what
good is that but like you know
but i think that kind of leaning that
kind of tilt towards like huh like
that's me like you resonate with
something and i'm not the first to say
this i think robert green also said this
like there's a
adults will often remember back to a
time where they interacted with
something sometimes it's an object or
sometimes it's an experience and it just
felt so good like it kind of drew you in
i would tell your young listeners to
and viewers to really
pay attention to that it can seem almost
trivial like it's rarely about the thing
you're looking at or the thing you're
doing but sometimes it's the sensation
of running sometimes it's it's it's the
sensation of
viewing seeing something or hearing
something because there's a hint there
and it's the it's not really about what
you're looking at or you're doing it's
that feeling like learn it that feeling
is your compass
like that's your true north because
that's the feeling you want to get to
for to find
you know the mate for your life the you
know the partner for your life the
the career track and over time you're
gonna pivot right i mean you're not
gonna get it on the first try
i eventually my story of science started
there it told me right there i
felt it in that conversation with my dad
and then my compass was all over the
place and spinning and eventually it's
it's come back
i found it but getting in get in touch
with that feeling and if this seems at
all abstract i would do it as an
experiment
i would sit in a chair
and i would think about something you
don't like
like really don't like and i would pay
attention to what that feels like in
your mind and in your body i'm not a
very somatic person i'm not somebody who
like feels stuff at the level of the
body i've always felt like my emotions
were my head so when people talk about
like their emotions in their
other places i'm just like
i don't get it
but i would encourage them to think
about that and then i would encourage
them to think about something they
really like
it could be roller coasters could be
music could be
get specific and to get in touch with
that feeling and that feeling is your
guide
that feeling is your compass because the
nervous system
it's not mystical the nervous system
will orient toward the things that it's
best equipped to do
it really well
and i really animals do this naturally
my bulldog costello never tries to be
a different kind of dog he never fetched
once first time i threw the ball he
walked to the ball he sat down with the
ball he destroyed the ball because
that's what bulldogs do
you know throw to a retriever they bring
it back because the brain of the
retriever is wired to feel good by
retrieving yeah and the brain of the
bulldog is good to feel good by being
horizontal
with and pulling on things with their
they like to tug
so i think humans we're so we're similar
enough but we're different in the sense
that you have something installed in you
that feels right
and getting in touch with that feeling
is key and you're not and i should tell
that there's you're not going to get it
right away this is a practice you learn
like shooting basketballs or math you do
it over and over so that but if you get
started young at eight or nine oh my
goodness great and if you do it when
you're 12 or even if you're 60 and you
do this
you'll find that pretty soon you start
steering in these directions i i do
believe it's a nervous i think our it's
a neural there's a real physical
substrate for this it's not mysticism
the brain is basically designed to be
customized in the early part of life and
then to implement those algorithms and
that circuitry for the rest of your of
its life
and so the brain can change in adulthood
and it can change provided that there's
an emphasis on some perceptual event so
in other words if you want to change
your brain as an adult let's say you
want to be less anxious you want to
learn a new language you want to be
more functional in some way presumably
the key thing is to bring
focus to some particular perception
of something that's happening during the
learning process and the reason for that
is that there's a neurochemical system
involving acetylcholine
and it comes from these two little
nuclei down in the base of the brain
called nucleus basalis
all day long you're doing things in a
reflexive way but when you do something
and you think about it
very intensely acetylcholine is released
from basalis at the precise neurons that
were involved in that behavior and it
marks those for change during sleep or
during deep rest later so for people
that want to change their brain
the power of focus is really the entry
point and the ability to access deep
rest and sleep
because most people don't realize this
but neuroplasticity is triggered by
intense focus
but neuroplasticity occurs during deep
sleep and rest one of the things that's
really important also to think about how
the brain works in terms of plasticity
and all this stuff is
what the brain really wants to do is
also pass as much of what it does after
reflexive behavior as possible so
yeah so when we're talking about focus i
think it can get a little bit vague but
it might be useful think about like what
exactly is focus and what triggers
plasticity
so the brain loves to be able to just do
things pick up coffee cups and drink and
walk and talk and do things and not put
much energy into it when we decide to
focus what the brain really does is it
switches on a set of circuits that
involve the frontal cortex and nucleus
basalis and some others and it's trying
to understand duration how long
something's going to last path
what's going to happen and outcome what
ultimately is going to happen so
duration path and outcome you know the
the events of early 2020 are a good
example of this one of the reasons why
it's so exhausting to be alive in 2020
is because we are now having to pay
attention to duration path and outcome
how long is this thing going to last
when are
you know when are they going to open up
all businesses did i touch that door
handle does it matter you know right who
are the experts are there any experts
you know there are a lot of questions
whereas normally we can just move
through life without having to do all
that analysis
so
if it's a simple example like trying to
learn a new language or a new motor
skill or a new way of conceptualizing
something maybe somebody's in a
therapeutic process and they're trying
to work through a trauma or something
like that duration path and outcome
is
built into the networks of the brain we
can do that very easily but it takes
work and it almost has a feeling of
underlying agitation and frustration and
that's because the circuits that turn on
before acetylcholine are of the stress
system so when you or i decide we're
going to learn something and really dig
in
norepinephrine which is adrenaline is
secreted in the brain stem and in the
body and it brings about a state of
alertness
then our attention which is mostly a
diffuse light is brought to a particular
duration path in outcome analysis this
would be thinking about what somebody is
saying what are they really trying to
say a hard passage of reading
a hard you know set of math problems you
know a challenging physical workout
when you do that these two systems have
to work very hard and the adult brain
doesn't really want to change the
algorithms it learned in childhood but
if you do those two things you have
alertness and focus the acetylcholine
and the norepinephrine converge to mark
those synapses for change
and so dir so the way to think about
neuroplasticity if one wants to change
their brain is bring about the most
intense concentration you can to
something
and then later bring about the least
amount of concentration of that thing so
growth mindset and these dopamine
rewards that we subjectively apply are
not about
saying oh you know i had a terrible day
i performed poorly but you know what
it's great i just feel great anyway it's
not about that it's not about attaching
your sense of reward to the ultimate
goal
it's about attaching your sense of
reward to the fact that you're making
action steps that are generally in the
right direction the more you can reward
the effort process
the better off you are at building these
kinds of neural circuits and these kind
of tendencies to be able to lean into
anything challenging over essentially
any duration so how does this work like
how would somebody do this right well
keeping in mind that adrenaline and
epinephrine are all great for getting us
into action this is mother nature's way
of chemically making us feel kind of
agitated remember stress was designed to
agitate us to move us away from things
and toward things and i didn't have the
power of concentration i hadn't read all
the good books that gun high school
students read growing up i had to
learn how to speak properly i learned
how to learn how to think properly and
really learn how to
commit to something that was very linear
and at times was very painful and and i
went to some pretty extreme things i um
you know i actually used to
set a timer
uh and i wouldn't allow myself to get
out of the chair until i was the timer
went off right so and i would experience
extreme agitation but over time i got
pretty good and now i can do long stints
of work and when we step back and we
look at what that really entails at a
neurochemical level we have reward
systems in the brain they generally fall
into two categories there are the reward
systems that make you feel really good
with kind of the here and now and
everything that's within the confines of
your skin and the things you already
have you know love of your dog love of
your spouse
gratitude for all the things you happen
to have and that and those are generally
governed by the release of molecules
like serotonin and oxytocin okay
but then there's another reward system
which is the one that drove a lot of
human evolution which is the dopamine
reward system now dopamine is a
very misunderstood molecule it's often
talked about only in the context of
reward like i'm going to work to this
goal i'm going to build my company i'm
going to you know get tenure as a
professor whatever it is and you reach
it and you get this dopamine reward and
indeed that's true but what's often not
discussed is that dopamine is secreted
enroute to rewards while you pursue
rewards
now
the ability to tap into that system
to subjectively amplify that pathway of
reward in pursuit of goals is an
absolute game changer when it comes to
things like
anything challenging that of long
duration or uncertainty or getting
through this cove you know pandemic
situation
but the amazing thing is remember the
brain only does five things and we get
to decide which of those sensations and
perceptions have relevance and which
ones don't or which ones are attached to
a goal and which ones aren't so growth
mindset in its purest form is the
attachment of these reward systems to
the effort process to the friction
process and not just to obtaining a
reward and just as a kind of final point
to that there's a very um well-known
body of literature and neuroscience at
least among neuroscientists that talks
about something called reward prediction
error and it says if you can dose the
dopamine
subjectively as you go through the
pursuit of something and then have a lot
of dopamine when you reach that thing
it's very likely that you're going to
reinforce that circuit there will be
neural plasticity and that circuit will
become stronger so the next time you
will revisit those sets of behaviors the
opposite can happen too
where you're in real anticipation of
something this is going to be great this
is going to be great this can be great
and then you reach that goal and it's
kind of underwhelming and that generally
triggers this the circuit that i
referred to earlier this kind of
disappointment or pro-depressive circuit
so dopamine
is involved in reward but it's also
involved in the pursuit of rewards and
so as you reach a milestone or as you
tell yourself i'm on the right track
this friction i'm feeling this late
night this early morning this hard
conversation with somebody that doesn't
feel good i'm going to tell myself this
is for a larger purpose that's that
subjective insertion that abstraction
that we're talking about earlier and
when you start releasing dopamine to
those kinds of things there's
essentially no limit on the number of
things you can do or the energy to do
them so just as a last last point about
dopamine when we're in effort we're
always secreting adrenaline we're always
in pursuit and it's draining it's tiring
dopamine has this beautiful capacity to
buffer adrenaline and you know this
you've experienced this before because
if you've ever been working really
really hard maybe your team is depleted
everything's just a mess and somebody
cracks a joke and all of a sudden in an
instant it's like everything's reframed
that couldn't have been hormonal
hormones work on that on the schedule of
like hours to days to weeks it had to be
neurochemical it absolutely had to be
neurochemical and that neural chemical
is dopamine dude what you just described
is literally the scientific breakdown of
how you turn your life around i would
just tell people that that subjective
insertion is one of the most powerful
concepts i have ever heard in
neuroscience you're the only one i've
ever heard articulate it that succinctly
we can all apply these mechanisms and
these neurochemical reward schedules so
that the study that you're referring to
is a beautiful one
there's a classic study where
researchers not my lab put two rats or
you could do this with mice into a tube
and the tendency is for them to try and
push one or the other one out one always
wins and pushes the other one out we
call the one that got pushed out the
loser the one that pushed him out the
winner
here are the interesting things about
this
first of all the winner
will tend to win with other in other
battles even though these are just
pushing battles
more because it simply won the time
before the loser by losing will tend to
lose and so people say oh well that
explains a lot about society etc well
here's where it gets really interesting
you can even take a mouse or a rat and
push it from behind and make it the
winner and then on subsequent trials
where you're not pushing it it will tend
to win more often so the win doesn't
even have to come from itself
so
last year there was a very important
paper published about this where a set
of researchers just said well what is it
like what is this winning circuit and
this losing circuit enough with the
demonstration that this happens like
what's happening on what's under the
hood and so they went into the brain and
they identified
a brain area which is part of the
frontal cortex the area that we
typically think about planning action
executive function all the kind of high
level stuff
and what they
discovered was this brain area is more
active in the winter
than in the loser in fact they could
take the loser and over stimulate this
area and turn the losers into winners
now it gets even more ridiculous than
that if you quiet this brain area
winners become losers okay
and
and if you take a winner
and let's say at this tube battle and
you put them into let's say a cold
environment with a bunch of other mice
and you have just a warm corner mice
don't like to be cold and you say who
gets the warm corner right who gets the
luxury spot it's always the winner so it
even breaks down at the level of social
interactions and so you say okay all
right now we know that it's this brain
area it's this it's this one area of the
frontal cortex but what's it actually
doing right okay what's it actually tran
what how can we translate this turns out
this brain area that's responsible and
required for winning in this series of
experiments
is actually driving up the level of
activation
what you and i would call agitation or
stress to the point where that animal is
more likely to move forward it's simply
taking stress which is
wired into us in order to make us feel
agitated instead of
suppressing us you know instead of
saying you know i'm just going to sit
here i'm overwhelmed
i'm just going to move into action so
there's a circuit for winning there's a
the same circuit when it's
hypoactive not active enough is what
causes losing in these competitive
scenarios and similarly there's a
circuit for quitting there's an a
norepinephrine circuit in the brain stem
this was published in the last couple
years showing that when animals or
people are in constant effort eventually
that level of norepinephrine gets so
high that it triggers a circuit that
shuts down the motor control over the
limbs and you just say that's it i give
up i'm done so these mechanisms were
hardwired into us we all have them
whether or not it's from evolution
mother nature god the universe it is
it's irrelevant to the discussion that
these circuits exist in everybody and i
think it's a select few people who
really understand that forward action
is what drives these circuits it's
the ability to take that agitation
stress agitation increase our focus and
they bias us for movement and nature
wanted that they want us to move forward
in the face of challenge not to be
quiescent we weren't sitting around
battling tigers and saber-toothed tigers
all the time more likely we were in
caves and we were getting hungry and we
had to go out and search for things
agitation and stress were designed to
get us up and move us and when we try
and fight that too much and we try and
quiet that stress
that actually can be problematic you
have to decide are you gonna try and
quiet stress or are you gonna actually
lean into action that's critical choice
point for everybody who's experienced
anything negative or positive for that
matter
dude that that is so useful in terms of
getting people to understand how to get
themselves out of it this goes back to
this notion that
your thoughts are ultimately a choice
like you get to decide what you think
about it the mind
plays an important role in interpreting
whether or not it's overwhelming or
tolerable so intense breathing like
tumor breathing or ice baths or cold
showers or intense exercise like you
know high intensity interval training
type stuff
teaches the mind to be comfortable in
these higher stress states where in
other words it teaches people to be
comfortable when they have a lot of
adrenaline in their body this is
basically stress inoculation
but stress inoculation is not about not
getting stressed it's actually about
divorcing the mind-body relationship a
bit so that you're calm in the mind when
your body is very amplified yeah so if
you've ever done tumor type breathing or
you've done a cold shower the goal is to
get the adrenaline release and then calm
your mind and then calm your mind but
both those things
breathing and vision also run in reverse
meaning if we change our pattern of
breathing we change our inner state
if our state changes our breathing
changes so it's reciprocal it's
bidirectional likewise with vision when
we are excited or stressed the aperture
of our visual window shrinks we get that
soda straw view of the world when we are
relaxed the aperture of our vision
expands
but as well it runs in both directions
if we expand our view of the world
literally force our our visual field or
just it's very easy actually you can do
it no matter where you are right now if
you just try and expand your visual
field not by looking around or moving
your head or eyes but by trying to see
yourself in the environment that you're
in so you literally dilate your view so
you could see the ceiling in the floor
and the walls if you're inside or if
you're outdoors seeing as big an
aperture of your visual field or your
your visual environment as possible so
you're directing your attention to even
though you might remain looking straight
ahead you're just directing your
attention to as wide a peripheral view
horizontally and vertically as possible
is that what you mean that's right
exactly so essentially if you keep your
head and eyes mostly stationary you
don't have to be you know rigid about
rock steady but if you look forward and
you expand your field of view so you
kind of relax your eyes so that you can
see as much of your environment around
you as possible to the point where you
can see yourself in that environment
what you do is you are turning off the
attentional and believe it or not the
stress mechanisms that drive your
internal state towards stress
this is why when you go to a vista or
you view a horizon it's very relaxing
because you naturally go into panoramic
vision
when you are indoors you're looking at
your phone you're looking at a computer
or a camera or something of that sort or
you're talking to somebody or an intense
conversation you may not notice it but
your entire visual field shrinks to a
much smaller aperture and that drives an
increase in alertness in internal state
and we sometimes call that stress if
it's a negative experience if it's a
positive experience we might call that
love or obsession or fascination but
the important thing to realize is that
both vision and breathing
have a profound and very rapid effect on
our internal state of mind and body and
it runs in both directions
our internal state that could be
triggered by a text message or hearing
something that somebody says drives
changes in our breathing and our vision
but our breathing and our vision can
also drive changes in our internal state
and so that article in scientific
american
was a discussion about how we can
leverage the visual system and the
respiration the breathing system in
order to take control over our internal
state because
it's not just that 20 20 was stressful
it's that our internal state determines
everything it doesn't just determine if
we feel
like we're having a hard time falling
asleep or having a hard time focusing
for instance it also determines how we
batch time how we analyze
where we are in the world in terms of
our lifespan a good example this would
be when we are very stressed we fine
slice time this is why when people are
in a car accident or something they
might report that things were in slow
motion they're actually your frame rate
increases
whereas when you're very relaxed your
frame rate slows down and when we are
relaxed we get so-called perspective
we are able to say well this too shall
pass or i can place this stressful event
in a context so one thing that's just
fundamental to how our nervous system
works is that we are constantly placing
our experience both our immediate and
past
experience as well as our anticipation
of the future into some sort of larger
context and our visual system literally
how we are viewing the world at that
moment
dictates how we create perspective in
terms of states of mind sounds a little
bit abstract but it's actually it boils
right down to optics of the eye and very
concrete things like how you move your
eyes and how you view the world growth
mindset which is the academic discovery
and laboratory discovery of my colleague
carol dweck at stanford is the hallmark
of growth mindset is really two things
one is i'm not where i want to be now
but i but i will i'm capable of getting
there eventually the other is to attach
a sense of reward to the effort process
itself in fact don't reward the result
reward the effort that's right and if
you look at true high performers people
that are consistently good at what they
do they don't peek and go through the
post partum depression and crash and
come back and their life is a cycle of
ups and downs but really people who are
on that upward trajectory consistently
those people attach dopamine
to the effort process and actually
carol's one of her original studies on
the discovery of growth mindset was
these kids that loved doing math
problems that they knew they couldn't
get right
so it's like the people love puzzles but
in this case they knew they couldn't get
it right but they loved doing it and it
incidentally or not so instead only
these kids are fantastic at math when
there is a right answer because they're
they feel some sense of reward from the
effort process yeah now the cool thing
about dopamine
is that
it's very subjectively controlled we can
all learn to secrete dopamine in our
brain
in response to things
that are in a purely subjective way
our interpretation our interpretation
and but it has to be
attached to reality so you know one
should never confuse what is real right
so no so if you're if you're thinking
about the effort you're expending so
let's say somebody right now is
financially back on their heels and
they're setting up a new business for
instance and it's hard
if they can take a few moments or
minutes each day to reflect on
the fact that the effort process is
allowing them to climb out of their hole
potentially that it's giving them an
opportunity that it's
somehow
they are on the right path or they're or
if they're not in movement along that
path or at least oriented on the right
path they're not lying in bed all day
they're thinking
they're taking a step if they can reward
that process internally two things
happen first of all the brain circuits
that are associated with building
subjective rewards and dopamine get
stronger so you get better at that
process
and second and most importantly dopamine
has an amazing ability to buffer
adrenaline and buffer epinephrine and
what i mean by that is there was a study
that was published in the journal cell
excellent journal cell press journal a
couple years ago showing that with
repeated bouts of effort we use
and we release more and more epinephrine
it's kind of adrenaline but in the brain
with more effort every time every time
you put in effort so every time you make
look for this let's keep it if i were to
keep it in the business context every
time you make write that email every
time you let's see it's a person who's a
craftsman or a craftsman every time
you're working in the in the shop and
doing that every bit of effort
you're
taking a little bit of money out of this
epinephrine account you're spending
epinephrine at some point
those levels of epinephrine
get high enough that you you feel like
quitting it feels exhausted
this was done in a beautiful study
actually where um they control the
visual environments and they have the
subjects
exert effort and they can control the
visual environment so sometimes the
effort of taking steps and moving
forward is actually kind of pushing
forward and kind of swimming motion um
would give them the sensation that they
were actually making progress and other
times it was an exercise in futility
where they would just keep the the
visual world stationary and they would
expend effort and they didn't think they
were going anywhere
epinephrine's climbing climbing climbing
and eventually
they quit
now dopamine is able to push back on
that epinephrine and give you
anyone the the
feeling that you could continue and
maybe even the feeling that you want to
continue and you've seen this actually
football is a good example two teams
play
say the super bowl
both teams are max effort the entire
time yeah max effort
the team that wins
suddenly in a moment has the energy to
jump all over the place party for days
they can talk i mean they they they're
well that wasn't glycogen or stored
energy of any kind except it was neural
energy and what happened was effort is
this adrenaline adrenaline adrenaline
adrenaline eventually people quit they
just quit
the
dopamine is able to suppress that and so
then you're expending effort but you're
doing it from a place of feeling like
you have energy for it there was a paper
published
that essentially was asking why any
human or animal quits at any behavior
now certain behavior is like i can't
lift a car unless it's a very small car
can't lift a car but if it's we're
talking about running or we're talking
about
long bouts of work the question is why
do we quit like what is that it turns
out that every time we exert effort a
certain amount of noradrenaline in the
brain is released and there's a sort of
a counter in the brain stem and at some
point enough noradrenaline is released
and it shuts down
cognitive control deliberate control
over the motor circuitry and we quit
that's it but the thing that can restore
those levels or it can sort of reset
those levels lower and give us more gas
more mileage is dopamine and it makes
perfect sense because our species had to
move against very challenging things in
in nature and in in terms of in culture
at every stage of our evolution
including now 2020 is a good example of
this and when a good example would be
if you're really slogging it out and
things are miserable just think like the
worst family vacation everything is a
disaster or a very hard physical event
and someone cracks a joke
you almost immediately feel a sense of
relief
you see this in the team that wins the
super bowl both teams slogged it out you
have to believe they were both at max
effort the entire game look at the team
that wins they have extra energy they're
jumping all over the place so it can't
be physical energy it can't be glycogen
related it's not ketone related it's
nothing in the body in that sense it's
dopamine's ability to take that level of
norepinephrine and smack it back down
and so we can
learn this right i mean i think this is
where there's real power like in your
story
or the story that i'm familiar with
from your book like the the ability to
push through those pain points is
something that we really can export to
other aspects of life because it's the
same neurochemicals that are involved so
when you get to a particular location or
maybe i
recall um you know a portion where
you're just you're feeling lousy you
know you're injured or you feel like
you're hurt and you can reframe it
mentally
and think i'm actually still on the
ladder i'm still holding on to a rum i
know at least that much i'm still
breathing i know that much and the lift
that we get is not some psychological
pump up it's a neurochemical thing it's
dopamine suppressing norepinephrine and
saying you're on the right path you can
keep going it's a permission to keep
going and we grant that permission to
ourselves no one grants that permission
to us i think one of the other kind of
misconceptions that we want to dissolve
is this idea that
external rewards can actually propel us
down long paths of of success and high
performance and they can't no it's a
it's an internal sustainable fuel source
yeah yeah i have a friend from the seal
teams and somebody asked us recently we
were given a talk
and somebody said how can i make sure
that i continue to self-reward and i'm
not driven by these um external rewards
how can i continue to have that drive
and uh his answer was very good he said
give away all the external rewards you
know now not all everyone can afford to
do it's just about you and you it's just
you and you and the more attached
there's a famous stanford study done at
bing nursery school probably not far
from where you were in the dormitory
there's a little nursery school in
escondido village and they did this
study where they looked at kids that
liked to
playing during their recess it's all
recess in nursery school but
they're drawing
and they took the kids that really liked
to draw
and they started giving them little gold
stars on their drawings
and then they like the gold stars for a
kid that's an extrinsic reward and then
they stopped doing that and the kids
stopped drawing
they just they they associated the good
feeling of doing it with the external
rewards we have to be very cautious
about how much of our internal dopamine
we attach to external rewards if we want
to continue to grow
and pursue and focus and work hard if
you just want to get to some place and
cash in
then fine
but most people find themselves in a
pretty miserable place because their
dopamine was so attached to external
rewards they need more and more of well
breathing can be used to shift the brain
into different states and um i've talked
to david about this and so i'm sort of
borrowing from his words here so i want
to be fair that these are from those
conversations
so hypnosis inevitably involves relaxing
the nervous system taking the nervous
system into states that are more like
sleep now what i mean by that is in high
alert states where you're talking and
planning and inaction and stress in
particular
the brain is very linear it's saying
okay if this then this if then then this
is why we tend to be forward thinking
when we're when we're stressed we tend
to be not in our immediate experience
but really kind of forward thinking so
clinical hypnosis involves
going into a state of deeper relaxation
so that our analysis of space and time
meaning the way that the brain is
perceiving events is slightly
dismantled so that it's a little bit
dreamlike and then the hypnotist and
this could be by listening to a script
or listening to a hypnotherapist
starts to narrow our context take our
thoughts if you will it down a
particular path and that path could be
one of um stress reduction or
smoking cessation um hypnosis is
incidentally is very good for treatment
of smoking cessation or
for feelings of well-being or
confronting traumas so what it is is
it's really opening up the window for
neural plasticity which is of course the
brain's ability to change in response to
experience to trigger neuroplasticity
you have to have focus especially as an
adult you need acetylcholine released
but
high levels of attention acetylcholine
and norepinephrine together
norepinephrine to create that sense of
urgency and acetylcholine to bring that
spotlight of focus in really really
tight that triggers plasticity but the
actual it marks certain synapses in the
brain for change but the actual changes
in the synapses the rewiring okay that
happens during states of sleep and deep
rest
so this is why when you're trying to
learn a motor skill you go and you go in
your tennis serve it's not happening
it's not happening you take a break you
come back and you nail it you're like
wait what happened well you needed time
to set those circuits in motion and
allow them to do to the rewire and the
sort of adaptation hypnosis seems to
capture both the high attentional state
and the deep relaxation at the same time
it's this very unusual state of mind
where you're neither asleep nor awake
and in tight focus or narrow focus
and it's very clear that it leads to
these rapid changes in behavior because
you're rewiring the brain and the reason
you're able to rewire the brain so
quickly is because you're getting the
trigger event the focus
and you're also getting the relaxation
event simultaneously and so it's much
faster than separating out the learning
trigger from the actual rewiring of the
brain
my lab has a deep interest and david
spiegel's lab has a deep interest now in
using respiration or breathing to shift
our state to either heightened states of
focus and alertness to open up
neuroplasticity dopamine is not just
about reward it's one of the biggest
misconceptions dopamine is about
motivation
and drive it's like a jet that propels
you along a path
how do we get more dopamine you practice
subjectively releasing dopamine in your
mind like wow okay so
that's a great question first of all
there are ways you can get more dopamine
release
through thoughts or through drugs or
through supplements i want to be really
clear there is a drug there are two
drugs actually that will cause massive
release of dopamine they're called
cocaine and methamphetamine
the problem that's what gets us addicted
because it feels so good the problem is
exactly the problem is cocaine and
methamphetamine
stimulates so much dopamine release
that the
drug becomes the only source it becomes
the goal of the path it becomes the path
and the destination and you look at
people's lives when they do a lot of
cocaine and methamphetamine and that
baseline on their life goes
dopamine is this incredibly powerful
molecule that allows us to buffer the
effort process it allows us to be an
effort longer and it allows us to
actually eventually enjoy the process of
effort and not think about the reward
but just say oh i'm enjoying the process
right well you just described the first
step the first step in learning to
attach dopamine to the effort process
which is the key
operation in order to succeed is to
be very careful about how much you focus
on the end goal keeping the goal in mind
is important for like a proper
orientation you have to know the
ultimate destination but if at any point
we were to evaluate our progress
relative to that end goal
or if we don't know what the end goal is
there's a huge gap there and it can feel
overwhelming the key to this is if we
want to be very concrete we should
probably focus on actions and i'll use
fitness as an example because it
translates to everybody whereas you know
people's circumstances differ let's say
somebody really wants to take on a
fitness routine
they hate running or they want to lose
weight in a healthy way this kind of
thing so we've all heard the example
well you put your shoes by the door on
day one day two you put them on day
three you go out the door day four you
walk around the block and then you know
and then eventually like they're running
marathons okay
great but to sustain that behavior or
even to make the behavior pleasureful
and to give you energy the key is to
subjectively reward those steps so it's
not going to be let's say i go out and i
run a mile
and my goal is to run 10 miles in a few
weeks the key is as you're in the strain
of that mild the hard part you want to
tell yourself
this is the good part this is the part
that gives me energy and i'll be very
surprised if people don't actually feel
like they could continue further so it's
a journey of a thousand miles starts
with the single is made up of you know
single steps but the key is to reward
the harder steps not the easier ones and
not the ones where you get the thing
that you want there's a process i'm
going through right now where i'm trying
to write a book and um it's hard and
it's hard and i was told that the harder
it is the better i'm probably doing it i
was like great my editor's ready to kill
me and because i'm slow and i and i know
and i'm a very slow person i i drive
people crazy i'm like glacially slow
because science is slow and i like to
get things right i want to rush it yeah
i like to get things right but i'm very
proud of the fact that everything we've
published i can stand behind it was the
best we could do with the tools at the
time and i just know that when i look
back on a writing career or a scientific
career i want to be able to say you know
every journal we put it in was rock
solid everything was rock solid we had
fun doing it the relationship so i go
slow yeah but as a consequence what i'm
finding is
there are a lot of interferences these
days i'm i'm i think social media is
great i teach neuroscience on social
media because i think it's important to
do public education
too but it's incredible and it's it's
incredible how much time and energy it
can take so what i've started doing now
is i turn off my phone and i lock it in
safe
and i experience extreme anxiety right
it's so weird why is that is it because
it gives you so much dopamine that when
you're not having it well this is scary
because i actually think um brief
anecdote on the weekend i was driving
there's a kid that i mentor and i picked
up my phone and i was texting while i
was driving and he said to me this was
really embarrassing for me he said
you know
i wish you wouldn't text while you drive
and i put it and i put it down and i
realized this is crazy i know that i
that my life in his life is far more
important and the lives of the people
around me are far more important than
any text message which means i wasn't
doing it rationally it's just pure
reflex at this point so i would i don't
think i pick up the phone because i'm i
don't even know what i'm looking for
there anymore it's just become reflexive
so for me lately
the longer i can keep that phone in a
safe and write on a grant or my or this
book
what i tell myself is the agitation is
good i'm it's at least i'm not doing
that and then i find that as i start to
write and i
get into the process i start feeling
good about it and i'll pause and say
okay i have control i have ultimate
control over my behavior i can put that
thing away there might be a nuclear war
out there and
i'm just doing this anyway i have
control over my thoughts my feelings and
behavior so i tell myself that and then
i find i have immense energy and all i
want to do is write and i kind of tunnel
into the process wow and i think that
sometimes people need to write these
things out for themselves so it's really
concrete i think some people are so
unskilled at subjective rewards that
writing it out is really powerful so
what would you write out for yourself as
a subjective reward for this experience
as long as i'm writing i'm on the right
path
as long as i'm not writing and looking
at my phone i'm not on the right path
because for me the the two or three
things that are most important for my
career are writing grants working on
this book manuscript and writing
scientific manuscripts i mean there are
other things as well anything else that
you're not doing is is holding you back
from doing that that's right so you need
to be focused center mass forward on
doing those things that's right so i
don't do any jumping around power poses
things like that i will use tools to
kind of ramp up my dope i mean there are
certain songs that are really embedded
in my emotionally my emotional thing
that go back to you know when i was a
you know
while you know skateboarding punk rock
teenager that will get me fired up
and i think there's real utility that's
pure dopamine you know a lot of people
hashtag growth mindset is one of the
most popular hashtags in social media
but most people don't actually know what
it means and then again this is carol
dweck's discovery not mine it was
discovered in a group of kids that were
doing math problems or other kinds of
puzzles that they knew they couldn't get
right but they enjoyed doing them and
they perform exceedingly well on lots of
sorts of tests of that sort
when there is the right answer of course
and so what they do is they somehow
they're wired for effort they're wired
for the puzzle not for the solution and
when i say puzzle i don't mean the noun
puzzle i mean the verb for being puzzled
it for them feels good and so we need to
think uh if we're talking about the
nervous system and we want to make it
actionable for high performance whether
or not it's in business or sport or
otherwise we want to think in terms of
processes not events and verbs not nouns
so growth mindset as a verb as an action
item you know uh reward as a verb not
just as a oh you're going to just pat
yourself on the back like it's no it's
what you internalize it's a process
that's how the neural circuits that
underlie reward get stronger and the
beauty of of the brain is that you have
this thing of neural plasticity which is
its ability to change itself throughout
the whole lifespan
and the more you practice this the
better you get at it and it does not
mean you're walking around talking
delusionally about how great life is
when everything is terrible it means you
might even be very stoic you might be
hopefully you're very rational but you
have the energy to for everybody one is
cold water which is great because it
most of the time it can't kill you
right it's not like heat which can kill
you it's cold water and sleep
deprivation
and so the ability to do these like what
i'm calling dpos this uh duration path
and outcome steps and procedures is
great on when you're rested you know uh
you know when you have a when you're
well fed well slept you can do anything
you can be in any hard conversation you
can work through anything so what they
do is they start taking the autonomic
nervous system which is
these deep reserves of the nervous
system
that when our autonomic nervous system
is off it starts making us
pay more attention to how we feel than
the demands of the world around us
remember that yeah basic challenge in
the nervous system and so sleep
deprivation
is the best way that you can pull
somebody down from their ability to
analyze duration path and outcome and
reward themselves sleep deprivation is
the way in which you essentially pull
apart the nervous system and the way
that it wants to function because
it's very easy again rested to do all
this but so what they do is they sleep
deprived people they put them in cold
water they're trying to get them more in
touch with the way that they feel inside
than what they need to do in response to
the external demands right everyone i
know that's made it through that process
did it slightly differently but i'll
tell you how they didn't do it they
didn't do it through sheer grit and
determination they did it through
attaching a sense of meaning they did it
by
micro
slicing the day or slicing the day into
a series of meals that they just needed
to get to and then rewarding themselves
for getting to that next milestone so
they don't know i mean most of them
you know probably had very low concept
of dopamine and norepinephrine but
that's the process that's also the
process i think that allows someone to
finish an ultra i've never run an ultra
but i think that process of self-reward
is
grit and resilience in a kind of
neurochemical definition yeah and i
think it's a thing that anybody can tap
into and i think it's therefore i think
it's it's so key because i think people
think that
uh it's just so key that people
understand excuse me that these circuits
are not unique
to people who run ultras or people that
make it through
uh you know stringent filter special
operations command yeah it's the same
thing that it is interesting yeah so why
why fear why do we have fears why do we
have trauma why do we have shame and
here's the stinger it was all set up for
you in your youth i don't want to focus
on the bad but most of the stuff when
you're young you're just a passive
learning machine it's all coming in
little kids are learning three languages
with no accents flexibly they're not
even thinking about they're learning
instruments you know someone asked a
great question the other day at the
workshop wait now i know i want all that
stuff how come it's so much tougher and
there's a lot of biology that i'd be
happy to tell you about that explains
why that all shuts down after these
so-called critical periods during
development so what happens when you're
an adult and you want to change your
brain so now i'm going to get into stuff
that's that hopefully is useful to you
okay so these basic facts that changing
your brain in a real way as an adult
requires that you
do particular things that activate
particular chemical systems in your
brain so how do you do that right i
could tell you all about the chemicals
and i'll tell you a little bit about
them but how do you do it okay so
this is a right here right now urgent
situation car wreck it's terrible you
can imagine any other trauma in its
place when that happens a little area in
the base of the brain the name isn't
important but if you care it's called
nucleus basalis
does its job which is just it's an alert
system it puts all its attention on
right here right now get everybody safe
it's your alert system and it has this
effect of dumping out
a certain chemical called acetylcholine
at specific locations in the brain that
are paired with that experience and
forever that experience will be
traumatic unless something else is done
okay so there's some nuance and some
details to this but that pretty much
summarizes it it's been replicated many
many times in dozens of studies you can
pair pretty much any experience with
stimulation of nucleus basalis this
thing in the in the base of the brain
and that experience will be mapped or
remapped in your brain as an adult and
that's remarkable it's also exciting
because then i someone like me says well
then how do i change my experience how
do i change the meaning of what happens
how do i change something from traumatic
to positive
the good news is nucleus basalis is just
a slave to whatever
is exciting traumatic it likes emotion
it like it likes peaks and lows and so
if acetylcholine is released that means
you can massively change your brain at
that moment with whatever's paired with
it and so when you get into a peak state
here you're jumping up and down or in a
really low state and you're thinking how
miserable something is you have to be
really careful because those are the
things that you're wiring in all right
so you can move to a state like this
about driving later if you form enough
associations with driving to really
eliminate to override the fear you need
to create a positive experience in its
place
so how do you do that
so i'm going to tell you that the way to
do that is not to think too hard and to
not verbalize things too much and this
is coming from someone who spent 25
years three times a week on a couch
letting subconscious things geyser up
and that's where i really learned that
it was really the things that you don't
realize that have the potential to have
the most impact but this power of
emotion the ability to couple really
strong emotions with things is so useful
if you want to change your brain for the
better and the way you do that
is clear in the physical space we all
know this story there are many news
cases like this woman's child stuck
under car super human strength we heard
a lot of amazing stories about
desperation jj's story was one of
desperation she's like no i'm not going
to accept
failure because failure in the case in
the case she was describing was
potentially the death of her child so
desperation is a strong one and it's
motivate motivated by fear but what if
you're not in a desperate state and you
really want to do something in that case
there's something remarkable and then we
should and we should ask ourselves why
are children such great passive learners
they're not trying they're just learning
they're coming home with all sorts of
things sometimes things you don't want
them to come home with
right it's because they have this
element of play and what is play play
isn't just movement although it includes
movement it's giving things everything
you've got but keeping it in perspective
it's that sweet spot of enjoying life
and trying really really hard at it at
the same time it's essentially what we
all
strive for and there are these
incredible cases throughout history
famous scientists because i grew up in a
house where people you know revered
scientists like like richard feynman
nobel prize winner he's most famous for
bongo drumming naked on the roof of
caltech and he became an amazing artist
in his 60s and he developed all sorts of
other skills and he always had this
childlike way of looking at the world he
never let himself get stuck in his ways
never became a curmudgeon and a
remarkable man and that's something that
i if you come away with nothing else i
encourage you to do that you want your
brain to change stay light stay loose
but give it everything you've got can a
person make it so they never
get depressed they never react to
um
their perception their
people's actions towards them where they
never get to a state of uh i don't feel
good i'm feeling more depressed
i'm in a dark place now i'm stuck in
this place is there a way that we could
ever
defend ourselves against negative
stressors negative emotions or are we
just
are they do we need them as well to have
contrast in life well there's sort of
two views on this um i'll reveal mine
after i um sort of
uh explain the two views one is that
these states i guess i'm i'm
automatically calling things like
depression a state of mind
so when i say state of mind i mean brain
and body because your body is really
feeling
it's like the brain is connected to the
body right and so if you're saying
internally the thought of like
i'm depressed i don't feel good or i'm
sad or lonely or i'm not good enough the
body's going to react is that what i'm
understanding absolutely the body is
going to manifest what the mind is
telling you absolutely the thought the
idea you're going to be like i'm sad i'm
not good enough you're going to shrink
right is that right that's right i mean
they're really two forms of depression
and sometimes they're intermixed but one
is anxiety-associated depression and you
you if you've ever experienced it or for
anyone that's experienced it they feel
agitation in their body
and their mind races but in their body
so the body is recruited
there are also depressive states
that people feel very fatigued and
exhausted it's been overwhelmed and they
also experience that in their body the
idea of getting out of bed in the
morning is hard
motivating to exercise doing the sorts
of things that we know
are powerful for pushing back on
depression
so
the body is recruited i think
most people would say that
depressive states are bad when they
bring down the baseline on life i
just to as a brief aside anytime there's
a question about mental health or
addiction or trauma or anything
one could look at it and make up some
argument of low evolutionarily this
makes sense we all get depressed but
we have to be fair to the person
experiencing it of course and have
sensitivity that some behaviors will
keep the baseline of our life steady
meaning job relationships etc will
continue as they are other activities
will tend to improve the baseline on our
life job activities relationship etc
will will improve and then there's some
things like heroin
which
does very quickly we can predict that
very quickly the baseline on life is
going to creep down regardless of who
that person is right so people say can
you get addicted to water well maybe but
i have to drink a lot of water before
the baseline of my life starts to go
down so sure it feels uncomfortable
that's just like man i'm so bloated
exactly right so we tend to throw around
things like addiction and depression a
little loosely so yeah i think that it's
fair to say that depression is wired
into us as a possible state that we can
all fall into
but that it's very important in my
opinion
that humans have tools
to remove themselves from that state
of course to avoid tragedies like
suicide but also because when the
baseline on someone's life goes down far
enough
they find it increasingly hard to do the
sorts of things that are going to get
them out of depression so you or i could
say so they stay in that state of
depression that's right it's too hard to
go work out it's too hard to change my
habit of eating healthier so i'm going
to stay
i'm going to keep eating ice cream which
is gonna make my body
you know depressed that's right right if
i can keep eating bad foods if i keep
staying up until 4 a.m if i keep staying
in the toxic relationship i want to feel
depressed that's right and eventually
because of this very
inseparable relationship between the
brain and body eventually what happens
is that because the brain controls the
body but also the body can control the
brain
people lose the ability to intervene in
this depressive process so you or i
could say look
if someone who's depressed they what
they need to do is get up early get some
light in their eyes um get some movement
i know you put this information out
there which i love because these the
those tips are grounded
in uh they're not even tips they're
really tools and they're very powerful
because they're grounded in excellent
science you get that dopamine release
early in the day that's anti-depressive
you time your sleep better when you get
sun in your eyes and you get movement
early in the day
for most people that's accessible and
they should be they absolutely should be
doing it everyone should be doing that
but for people who are far enough down
that path of depression
because the body and the mind have this
relationship that's so close
there is a crossover point where
they really can't do those activities
because they're so far deep into the
depression the body won't do what they
decide to do
and so now i'm not trying to give anyone
a pass because ultimately we are all
responsible for our own mental health
certainly
adults more than kids but you know we're
all responsible for our own mental
health and only we can direct our own
brain changes that's the that's the
stinger once we're you know 25 years and
older we are the only ones that can
change our brain and we can talk about
neuroplasticity if you like but the
depressed person
has to take responsibility for their
behavior but this is why it's so
important to catch this brain body
relationship early and build
routines that keep one out of depression
so that was a long path back to answer
your question succinctly i hope which is
we can stay out of depression but we
have to keep depression at bay by doing
things regularly we have these so-called
receptors in the eyes and the ears and
the nose and the mouth on the skin
that take physical entities in the in
the universe that are real fixed
non-negotiable things like sound waves
and photons of light and chemicals in
the environment traveling that make it
into our nose and things like that
and convert those into the second thing
which is perceptions
so the nervous system's responsibility
is to take those sensations which are
non-negotiable
and
perceive certain ones and not others so
for instance right now until i say you
know what's the sensation of your feet
contacting the floor or the bottoms of
your shoes you weren't thinking about it
but those pressure receptors were being
engaged the entire time so your
perception
is like a window or a spotlight that's
very much linked to attention
then there are emotions often called
feelings
and those are really designed
to push us down particular avenues of
perception and
the next thing which are thoughts
okay so we've got sensation perception
feelings and then there are thoughts
which really have a lot to do with what
we're perceiving and the way we're
organizing those perceptions what they
mean and generally that's put into the
context of what we already know or
memories
and then the fifth thing is behaviors
or actions and of course neurons are
responsible for generating actions and
they're really two kinds of actions
there are the actions that you generate
reflexively like your breathing and your
heart rate right now are largely
reflexive or you could decide troll of
your respiration
and be make it voluntary right and not
just reflexive so those five things
sensations perceptions feelings thoughts
and actions really encompass all of our
life experience and that's
from the very mundane of getting up in
the morning and brushing your teeth to
the most awe-inspiring uh goal-motivated
uh pinnacle moments of your life the
nervous system not the immune system not
the digestive system all of which are
important but the nervous system meaning
the brain spinal cord and the
connections with the body and the
connections from the body back to the
brain and spinal cord are responsible
for all of that
and as a just a final point the nervous
system is also responsible for telling
the immune system something that's very
relevant right now in this covid
pandemic
when to be active you know we don't
often think about the immune system as
governed by anything i want to just
mention about the diaphragm why it's so
important for what were these state
changes is that a lot of people talk
about the vagus nerve and all this stuff
the vagus and these connections between
the brain and this vagus nerve or the
gut
it's what gets activated when you're
really full and you eat a big meal and
you feel relaxed those are great but
it's very slow
the diaphragm is skeletal muscle just
like your bicep just like your tricep
just like your quadricep it is the only
internal organ except maybe a couple
muscles in your throat that are actually
skeletal muscle meaning it was designed
to be voluntarily moved and the
diaphragm isn't just designed to move
your lungs it also sends a signal
through the so-called phrenic nerve back
to the brain to inform your brain about
the status of your body so when you
breathe fast deliberately the reason you
feel kind of an elevated sense of
alertness is because the other chemicals
secrete but mostly because the phrenic
nerve is firing off it's telling you hey
the body's moving we're really running
now even though you're stationary in a
chair if you're doing breathing or if
you're breathing very slowly and
rhythmically right box type breathing or
you know slow slow breathing
your diaphragm is telling your brain hey
we're calm we're good and you calm down
very quickly on the order of seconds and
so once you start tapping into this you
start realizing okay movement of the
body was designed to inform the brain of
where to be not just the brain telling
the body and how does the body
communicate with the brain through the
phrenic nerve from the diaphragm so my
lab is really pursuing two questions and
this is still being worked out so i just
want to highlight that it's still in
progress
but
certain patterns of breathing will calm
you very much like entering a hypnotic
state and so you have a subset of
neurons in your brain stem that are
responsible for sighing is it you have a
subset of neurons in your brainstem
responsible for for coughing subset of
neurons responsible for laughter and a
subset of neurons in your brain stem for
sign this was a paper published in
nature this is a real thing these
neurons are every so often and your dog
does this too
you inhale twice
and then you exhale long
now that double inhale
best done through the nose on the
inhales and then long exhale through the
mouth
activates these side neurons that
trigger the so called calming reflex the
parasympathetic arm of the nervous
system so we have a hard-wired mechanism
a set of neurons connection in the
diaphragm and back again from the
diaphragm to the brain that was designed
to activate calm
and when people ask me how should i
breathe to calm myself down i always say
double inhale through the nose followed
by exhales two or three of those will
reset your autonomic nervous system
faster than any other mechanism we're
aware of
because it's really capitalizing on a
set of neural circuits now once you're
calm you say well how do i get into
plasticity states there you want to go
the other direction
that's going to be inhaling a lot more
than you exhale you're going to be
driving in more oxygen than you are
breathing out
generally carbon dioxide and that will
lead to states that are kind of more
elevated this is typical of things like
tumor breathing wim hof breathing
kundalini breathing and when people
enter those states
their whole world changes because it
shuts off the frontal cortex it really
this is why sometimes people pass out or
they feel like they want to get up and
move you know you get some odd behavior
when you're doing this kind of thing
so the key is if you want to access
states of heightened plasticity let's
say you want to learn faster where you
want to be more um
you want to bring more out of some
physical training that you're doing the
key is to apply those principles first
you need to focus you need to bring
yourself to that heightened state of
alertness you can breathe to do that so
this would be super oxygenated breathing
then you want to drop into a state of
calm and you do that by these a couple
maybe two or three rounds of inhale
inhale exhale inhale inhale exhale and
then now your brain is in a state we
believe this is still again being worked
out in labs like mine and david's that
then you're in a state for heightened
learning
because you're in a state where
neurochemicals like acetylcholine are
going to be at levels that are higher
than they typically would be things like
noradrenaline slightly higher than they
typically would be but not in a
discombobulated way in a very regulated
way and the cool thing is you're
regulating them so you could argue you
know earlier we were talking about
subjective emotions and thoughts and all
these things but one thing that's
absolutely concrete is breathing i
always think of physical exercise
movement writing
whatever singing dancing talking those
are physical actions in the universe
then you have thoughts and somewhere in
between those is controlling your
respiration once you can control
everything that's within the confines of
your skull and skin once you can really
control that relationship that brain
body relationship you start to realize
that relationship is a lot like any
other relationship to forward action
it's just all happening within the
confines of my body so it's heightened
states of focus followed by states of
relaxation that are going to prime your
nervous system for learning and
plasticity just like hypnosis
sorry for the long-winded discussion
do
don't you dare apologize that is some of
the most powerful and useful information
literally ever i
i can't tell you how much i love what
you're studying
how do you get motivated well one way to
do that is if you are good at
subjectively attaching
dopamine to the pursuit just knowing
okay i really am hungry for this i'm
just i'm going to tell myself that you
know making you know making it one
percent of the way is a success and i'm
going to keep going and i'm going to
keep ratcheting on and that's great if
you can do that but for people that
can't do that understanding this
relationship with the pleasure pain
balance can be more powerful just
understanding the more friction and pain
that you experience the greater the
dopamine reward you will get later and
that serves as its own amplifier of the
whole process of pursuing more dopamine
and then the other aspect of it
is that any time that we're leaning into
action
you know it has the the possibility of
being an amplifying process or a
depleting process
and the key to that is making sure that
you're balancing the dopamine and
epinephrine systems you know epinephrine
being this molecule of universal
currency of energy output
could be out of hate or it could be out
of love epinephrine doesn't care and
actually dopamine doesn't care none of
these systems care about us they just
work underneath our underneath our
conscious control but when you start to
understand that
hitting the gas pedal is great but
hitting the gas pedal and then coming
off the gas pedal a little bit
you can kind of sit in a more relaxed
rpm actually allows you to go much
further i think that people
leaning into action is terrific i always
say you can either be back on your heels
flat footed or forward center of mass
the best situation is actually to be
right upright but just know that you can
be forward center of mass at any point
and you know that to take it back to sex
and reproduction because it's a salient
example the arc of of sex is very
interesting because when you think about
autonomic arousal it turns out that the
the arousal stage of sex actually
involves release of dopamine but is what
we call parasympathetic dominant it
actually has to be relaxed enough
in order to occur okay everyone can read
between the lines on this
orgasm is actually
a
i want to say full-blown it's a it's a
it is a sympathetic
nervous system driven response it's
identical to the stress system it's
driven by the same neural circuits as
stress
and then what comes afterward
the parasympathetic system goes back up
again it's that deep relaxation so
why do i say this not to talk about sex
to be
you know to to serve as a highlighter
but rather our species arrived here
because of this dance between arousal
and relaxation arousal and relaxation
and one thing we can say for sure about
every human being that's alive now is
that their parents at least once
mastered this dance of relaxed but not
and excited but not too excited then
really excited and then relaxed that
dance was mastered by all of our parents
and that's what delivered us here to
some extent and so i
what this means is that all the neural
circuits from the ones that led to our
conception to the ones that lead to us
pursuing goals have this
balance this almost like a like a seesaw
right there's activation and calm
activation and calm and it's that
dynamic process that's important to
master in every endeavor so we use sex
as an example but in pursuit of goals
you have to learn how to pursue
short-term goals
and like the goals within the day make a
cup of coffee and goal and long-term
goals and when i said dopamine is what's
setting the
your time perception it's an interval
timer
what you're saying is it's like the two
marshmallow experiment done at stanford
def defer the dopamine
and actually
if you can turn the weighting into the
dopamine and then
you can extend out the reward for you
know waiting for the second marshmallow
15 minutes later et cetera et cetera and
there are many many examples of this in
the psychology and neuroscience
literature and i would say finally in
2020 we finally as a field got a clear
idea of how dopamine is really working
because before it was all about
work dopamine hit right sex gives you a
doubling hit the internet gives you a
dopamine what we didn't realize is that
repeated engagement with these things
leads to dopamine depletion
and that the pain and pleasure balance
is always at work there are other things
that if it's a physical skill that
you're trying to learn
as opposed to just a mental skill then
there's a whole kingdom of things that
are fun for instance if it's a physical
skill you want to generate as many
repetitions as you safely can per unit
time so if you say i'm going to learn
dance you want a ball machine if you're
playing tennis exactly you literally
want to generate repetitions and in
particular you want to generate failures
every time you you give up bad serve
playing tennis oh yeah that activates
the circuits for focus and alertness for
the next yeah it's true that's right so
when you're losing that's right
so so that and a lot of people don't
like failures and so they back away from
it so remember the nervous system will
only change if you give it a reason to
do that and the other one that's kind of
an interesting twist on this is the way
the nervous system is wired is it wants
to pass off
all of its work to circuits that are
reflexive as much as it can you don't
think about walking anymore because you
learned how to walk but when you were
learning you were very focused on sure
one of the things that can set the stage
for more plasticity overall is when you
disrupt the vestibular or the balance
system
it does appear that whenever we are
physically off balance the brain is
primed to pay attention
and the mil the chemical milieu is such
that it can actually rewire itself
faster and whereas i think the 90s and
2000s brought out a lot of important
work on saying hey
er exercise of aerobic type or maybe
even weight training can create
neuroplasticity
it was that was great but it wasn't
directed enough it didn't say well what
kind of exercise yeah and what will get
me even more plasticity and so there are
some basal things about heart rate and
blood flow et cetera but anything that
involves balance
or coordination
it's incredible how fast the brain can
learn so things like dance martial arts
a real sport not just exercising and i'm
not no disrespect to the the accident
i'm more of a just an exerciser than a
sport guy
but
if you're
40 50 60 80 whatever learning a new
physical skill
we know is tremendously powerful for
opening up neuroplasticity broadly
so some people will even leverage this
where
after they finish some physical skill
learning or something they might take a
20-minute nap and then they might read
yeah they might try something so when we
see these people i've been learning
surfing i'm like 60 years old perfect so
similar and i'm like yes exactly
exactly i learned started learning
tennis when i was 45 and it's really a
challenge because it's not automatic and
i have to really focus and be present
well these and these individual cases
are are not necessarily the place to
hang our hat completely but for instance
the great physicist richard feynman he
was well known for learning bongo drums
in the six when he was in well it was in
the 60s but in his 60s then he became a
quite accomplished um
painter
later in life and you know his whole
thing was
approach all of these things from a
standpoint of play
with intense focus yeah and i think the
play element is key because the play
element keeps the agitation in check
so that when you're stepping on your
partner's feet trying to learn how to
dance or you're
failing miserably it it can frustration
is a real thing and so i think that the
element of playfulness some people call
it beginner's mind but i think
that should be the anchor point to
return to and people that maintain
curiosity or i should say that cultivate
curiosity and that cultivate a sense of
play and willingness to take on new
vestibular
experiences of all things they
show very
they show remarkable plasticity into
their late life and i think that
it all comes back to this thing that the
brain won't change unless
something changes in the weather of the
brain the overall milieu has to say oh
wait everything that's about to happen
is different yeah otherwise why would it
change there are other goals that are
very different last time we talked you
were learning spanish yeah still
learning yeah still learning and there's
a and there's a little bit more friction
there because it's very challenging it
takes more effort to lean in because you
when you don't already know how to do
something it's a very different goal
pursuit mm-hmm right sort of like so if
i already have my business and i've been
running it for a few years you know
certain practices of how to get to where
you've been that's right and you're
thinking how do i double my business
that's right it's different than i'm
trying to learn a whole new skill goal
right you already know how to forage for
water as opposed to you're some young
calf or some animal that needs to learn
how to walk
right so
you so i think
you know one big goal
of the sort that um you know we don't
actually have the skill set yet we're
not even aware that of what we need in
order to accomplish it per year seems
like a pretty good goal to me so
learning entirely new language or an
entirely new physical skill
but with any long-term goal the problem
is remember don't focus on the
destination that's right well so you
have to move the horizon in
but you have to remember there's that
one little pitfall that cul-de-sac that
i described where you'll tell people
this year i'm going to do blank and if
they reward you enough you might not do
it remember if you get enough dopamine
it's amazing i'm so happy you're doing
that congratulations and you say i know
i can do it and then you don't you sort
of lose the incentive to do it
so some a lot's been made out of making
uh goals public is it is it better to
make them public or not well so this is
this is a question i don't know i think
that in my case it has
um
for me
telling people several people that i'm
going to do something because i will
work very hard to avoid um humiliating
um but i tend to do that with things i
really want to do anyway but there's a
strong fear element like i'm afraid to
do this or i'm i'm kind of anxious about
doing this so i'll tell people
and then i'm like okay now i'm committed
yeah you gotta do this you gotta do it
now and i tell people that i'm certain
they're going to give me a hard time
yeah that's just my name right um and
i'm not trying to prove them wrong i'm
just trying to make sure that they don't
have any ground to stand on yeah and
that's how i do it i think for
some people
the
continuation of what they're already
doing if it's feeling like a lot of work
it's feeling exceedingly challenging and
they're like oh my god another year of
this another five years of that
i think that's when you have to move the
horizon in really close i think a lot of
people right now are feeling back on
their heels because 2020 was such a
trying year for a lot of people
so everyone many people are
recalibrating what's possible although
many people are feeling expansion and
they're really going to go forward full
steam so i think continuing in pursuits
that we already have some degree of
mastery over and thinking about where
could i notch that up another two or
three percent i think that's incredibly
valuable i think that provides a lot of
value to the individual to their
families and to society really because a
two percent improvement of like what
you're already doing is going to have an
outsized effect on what other people
receive
right even though for you you've been
down that road many times but taking on
a new pursuit in parallel to that means
really getting excited about the
possibility you give the jim carrey
example about the possibility and
starting to imagine what that would
actually be like to be well let's say
fluent in spanish and you can just do
this reflexively without having to try
that's totally within your reach and i
think there it makes sense to really
think about the end point quite a lot as
a way to get over those barriers
of fear because when you already know
how to do something there's no fear
barrier yeah it's just an energy barrier
right but when you're don't know how to
do something there's all this
sense of clunkiness that is really
uncomfortable beginner's mind is a
painful place that's so hard man a lot
of people think about it like beginner's
mind is such a you know it's such a
delightful place to be so hard the
friction the amount of energy to build
momentum is so challenging in the
beginning well this is where play
becomes very important because you know
the great physicist you know richard
feynman was also famous in addition to
being a you know physics phenom for
having the sense of play he learned to
bongo drum late in life he was became an
artist late in life and he had this
lightness and this and this kind of
joyful way to approach things humor at
oneself
is incredibly powerful now we know the
chemical basis for that laughing at
oneself is often the best way to move
forward really yeah because you you
i mean i do this well maybe i don't know
maybe i'm biased but i do this all the
time i'll just laugh at myself for how
worked up i can get about the fact that
a file won't load or something like that
i just laugh and it's crazy i mean and
all of a sudden i have the energy to do
it so what does that do for our brain
when we laugh at ourself but not but
there's probably a difference between
laughing ourselves or something like
that versus
making fun of something that's a bad
habit like i'm always shaming ourselves
we're not shaming ourselves
200 pounds overweight let me laugh at
myself shame is kind of written into
like who we are it's not about what
we're doing it has this element of like
who we are you know guilt is sort of
more about i forget who said this but it
wasn't me first so i just want to be
clear i recognize it wasn't me first
guilt is sort of more about
um what we did
you know shame is is like an identity
thing um laughing at ourselves yeah like
laughing ourselves like how ridiculous
the human mind can touch i mean let's
face it as brilliant as as the
the nervous system and our minds and our
bodies can be
they make a lot of mistakes
we are a fallible species we're not a
perfect
species and perfection should never be
the goal and if i finish a chapter
i will
stop for a moment
and i'll just kind of smile and laugh at
myself i'm big on like
self-reflection with humor and just
thinking this is crazy you know
my brain is under my control there would
be people out there that say there's no
free will but i do not believe that i
put my hands in a lot of brains you
stimulate certain brain areas people do
things you stimulate other brain areas
people think things
ultimately unless you have electrodes in
your head and someone's stimulating them
we are in control of our thoughts and
behaviors we can't control all of them
but my goal is to be as
you know deliberate and non-reflexive as
possible in life that's my goal from
when i wake up in the morning until i go
to sleep how do we get to that place
little by little and by rewarding each
thing if you get up
and you
used to make the bed exam make the bed
you're you're not back on your heels you
make a cup of coffee you sit down you
script out something in a journal you
exercise
maybe you call a relative that you think
might need to hear from you or that
you'd like to talk to you do something
in a deliberate way just being
deliberate and learning to push away the
things that are trying to make you
reflexive is so important the nervous
system is designed to orchestrate all
the processes in the body not just
thinking and not just behavior and
really can be divided into five things
so
there's sensation
and sensation is really bound or
restricted by the receptors in the body
so
receptors in the eye that perceive
photons light energy
receptors in the skin that perceive
pressure you know touch receptors
smell taste hearing etc
and the interesting thing about
sensation and the fact that the nervous
system needs to pay attention to
sensation is it's non-negotiable
the nervous system of humans is designed
to extract physical phenomenon from the
universe that are non-negotiable photons
of light i can't see in the infrared
with my eyes and i can't see ultraviolet
light with my eyes i can't perceive that
because i don't have the receptors for
it
so
you know other animals can perceive some
of those things but that leads us to the
next thing which is perception which is
which sensations are you paying
attention to so all the time you're
sensing things like right now your feet
are sensing the contact with your shoes
but you're not thinking about it until i
say that and then you shift your
perception right so perception is like
the spotlight so the brain wants to
constantly bring in sensation it's
non-negotiable what's coming in it's
just depending on your environment
perception is negotiable you can control
that because i just said shoes and you
thought about your feet and there you
are
then there are feelings which
can be a little bit nebulous but
feelings are a link between our emotion
and
it generally invokes the body sensations
in the body and concepts in the mind of
what those sensations are about that's
really what emotions are animals
definitely experience them i'm kind of
appalled to think that 10 years ago
people like do animals have emotions of
course they have emotions right because
those are bodily sensations merged with
some perception so of course they do
and then there's thoughts and thoughts
are interesting because thoughts happen
spontaneously think about like a web
browser that's constantly giving you
pop-ups
but thoughts can also be deliberate so
you and i can decide right now that
we're going to think about a plan for
something or we're going to think about
what's going on in the world so thoughts
happen spontaneously and they can be
deliberate and then the final thing is
behaviors and actions so the nervous
system is responsible for sensation
perception feelings thoughts and
behaviors
and what's interesting
we start to think about that as you're
like okay that's a lot
but what is the nervous system really
trying to accomplish like on any given
day or at any moment what's it trying to
accomplish and it's really trying to
accomplish one thing which is to take
perceptions of the outside world
and merge those with perceptions of the
inside world what we call interoception
and to link those
in a way that's
operating on our environment in the
appropriate way so what do i mean by
that so if i'm feeling anxious and i'm
in a very calm environment i'm going to
perceive that rapid heart rate and kind
of feeling of agitation in my body as
inappropriate for the moment
right and my goal then as a as an
organism is to adjust my my level of
what they call autonomic arousals or
alertness down
if i'm in a at a great party or i'm at a
wedding or it's a celebration or i'm at
a protest or you know um
then i might feel that
my level of alertness is appropriate for
my environment so the nervous system is
in this constant dynamic
interaction with the outside world and
trying to figure that out
one way and that this can be kind of
conceptualized is there's an emerging
idea that's kind of interesting about
impatience
so we've all had the feeling of being
impatient some people are far more
patient than others but if you've ever
been in line at the store
and you feel like something's going very
slowly you know the person in front of
you is taking a long time they're doing
some returns you're getting kind of
impatient maybe you're breathing in a
mask and you're like oh like you're you
know
what's the idea is that if you're
getting a certain frequency of pulses
from your body and if those pulses are
coming in quickly like you're perceiving
your yourself that enteroception quickly
it's like pulse pulse pulse pulse you're
going to be more geared towards your
internal representation and then you're
seeing what's going on in the outside
world and it seems like it's going very
slowly but there are other times when
you're in line at the store someone's
getting some returns and you're texting
on your phone you've had a great day
you've had a great run your family's in
great shape and you're fine why well the
frequency of those pulses that
interoception is matched pretty well to
your outside environment and so
impatience is really when your int
internal sort of metronome
is not matched well to the external
environment
there are other times when you're
feeling like your internal metronome is
tick tick tick and you've got a million
things coming at you through email or
text you've got a bunch of things and
you're feeling overwhelmed and tired
well in either case there's nothing
right or wrong it's just
your body and your brain are trying to
say what's going on in the outside world
and how well matched am i to it right so
if you think about some of the the sort
of core practices of mindfulness and
self-regulation of like focusing on
breathing or focusing on on you know
state of mind a lot of that is trying to
bring more awareness to your internal
state
but
what our brain is normally doing when
our eyes are open and we're interacting
in the world is we're constantly trying
to update our internal state to match
external demands of the world and this
harkens back to a you know like a really
early design of all nervous systems
which is how do you take an organism
that needs certain things food water
mates reproduction shelter how do you
move that organism how do you create a
system that will do that in best
relation to the environment and so what
mother nature has done is designed to
assist a series of systems
let's just take agitation and stress for
one if an animal or a human is very
thirsty you feel kind of agitated you
might get up and get a drink of water if
you're very thirsty it can put you into
a state of panic if you're extremely
thirsty and water is a limited resource
you might even result to violence to get
it or negotiation of some sort that you
wouldn't if you were calmer so the
stress and agitation we're designed to
actually mobilize the body to take us in
the direction of something that's
adaptive so you can start to see these
kind of core elements
of
what the brain and nervous system do
sensation perception feeling thought and
action and this
constant challenge of trying to match
our internal state to the external real
estate the outside world and you start
to see that the sensations that we call
stress or impatience or calm
are really the result of that those
attempts that the nervous system is
trying to perform they get very micro
they move the horizon in very close and
so if you can move the horizon to
something you know you can complete and
you reward that
you essentially are where you were
before you're just as strong if not
stronger but you're heading in the
direction you need to go you're not
depleting you're not spending out
anything and it feels a little weird
because none of us like to reward things
that aren't external but the ability to
control these internal reward schedules
is everything one thing that um you've
talked about that i think is
along these lines be interesting to see
if if they feel as related to you when
you know so much about it but for me at
a high level these feel very related
talked about somebody gets in a car
accident uh acetylcholine if i'm not
mistaken to what extent does our
subjective narrative the story the story
we tell ourselves actually means
something for the body
and to what extent does the body
actually mean something for the
subjective narrative the reason i call
it a brain body contract early on is
that
their the brain and the body are
constantly in dialogue so
you know the idea that when we're
depressed we tend to be in more
defensive type postures when we're
feeling good we tend to be in more like
relaxed and extended postures all true
but it does not mean that just by
occupying the extended posture that i'm
going to completely shift the mind right
that's a first step think about like two
interlocking gears it's one gear that
turns the other but then they need to
kind of dance together before you can
get the whole system going and how do
you get it to dance together exactly so
subjective
there is one way in which subjective
thought and deliberate thought is very
powerful over states of mind and body to
answer your question can you think your
way out of the ice bath being cold so a
couple things that are important first
of all just to
go a little deeper on what thoughts are
thoughts happen spontaneously all the
time they're popping up like a poorly
filtered internet connection
but
thoughts can also be deliberately
introduced for instance right now
i can say
okay have a thought
that um just decide to write your name
and your you can do that i'm gonna
decide to write my name and you can do
it so that's a deliberate thought which
says that you can introduce thoughts so
i think it's very hard to control
negative thoughts directly by trying to
suppress them
they ten generally they tend to just
want to continue to geyser up all the
time
but we can introduce a positive thought
an ability to control your levels of
stress in real time is extremely
powerful
it turns out you can do this using
physiology and neuroscience
your breathing can directly impact your
heart rate and your level of stress or
calm here's how it works
when you inhale
your diaphragm moves down
this creates more space in your thoracic
cavity and your heart actually gets a
little bit bigger
as a consequence the rate of blood flow
through that larger heart volume
slows down
a signal is sent from a group of neurons
on your heart called the sinoatrial node
that signal goes up to the brain and
your brain sends a signal to speed the
heart up
in other words inhaling
speeds your heart rate up
the opposite is true as well when you
exhale your diaphragm moves up
your heart gets a little bit smaller
because there's a little bit less space
in your thoracic cavity as a consequence
blood flows more quickly through that
smaller volume
the sinoatrial node registers that and
sends a signal to your brain
and the brain sends a signal to slow the
heart down so in other words inhaling
speeds your heart rate up exhaling slows
your heart rate down so if you want to
speed up your heart rate and be more
alert
inhale more or make those inhales more
vigorous more intense
if you want to calm down
you can do that quickly by making your
exhales slightly longer than your
inhales or making them more vigorous
this doesn't require any breath work
this is something that you can do in
real time and that's what's called
respiratory sinus arrhythmia that's the
technical phrase it's also the basis of
what's called heart rate variability or
hrv but all you need to remember is
inhaling deeper and longer will speed
your heart rate up exhaling longer and
more intensely will slow your heart rate
down and will allow you to calm down in
real time you can learn so much for
better or for worse i always say the
downside is that early in life you're
you have less control over your life
circumstances but your brain is very
plastic so there's a you know darken
light to that later in life you have a
lot more control generally over your
life circumstances but the brain becomes
less plastic however
we know based on nobel prize winning
work and
recent work in addition to that that the
neuromodulator acetylcholine is secreted
when we pay attention to something very
specific it acts as sort of a spotlight
in the brain making certain synapses the
connections between neurons more active
and more likely to be active again than
others so when you hear that song that
you love so much and it moves you and
you feel dopamine being pulsed into your
body that's a real thing you're actually
getting dopamine secretion you've formed
that deep association with that and
acetylcholine draws your attention to
that and that song is essentially wired
in a very indelible way into your
nervous system multiple you can probably
even with certain songs you can feel
your body start to energize because of
course the brain through connections
with your muscles controls your body
so
for things that are traumatic or
negative what we're really talking about
is neuroplasticity that's focused on
unlearning and most of the therapies for
this whether or not it's emdr eye
movement desensitization reprocessing or
it's traditional psychoanalysis and
psychotherapy or it's somatic embodied
release
big you know kundalini breathing type
almost all of those are designed to do
something which is to bring the person
or you bring yourself
into a state of heightened alertness
right you can't do this stuff when
you're sort of half asleep heightened
alertness and then focusing your
attention on the traumatic or negative
event this is the way that it works and
then pairing that was something new you
know traditionally this was done with
things like nlp or in talk therapy where
people would feel
the relation the positive relationship
with the therapist that was kind of the
main rationale
in association with this very traumatic
sometimes even you know shameful type
events and the idea is that you you
would simultaneously have those two
experiences the negative one and the
feeling of safety and you would rewire
those circuitries i actually believe
that can work but it can take a lot of
times it can take a lot of visits to the
therapist which is not to say it's bad
it's just not everyone has access to
those resources
things like eye movement desensitization
reprocessing simply moving the eyes
laterally while recounting these
negative events the woman who devised
this
figured out
that somehow when people recount these
traumatic experiences when they're doing
these lateralized eye movements not
vertical eye movements they
somehow
separate out the negative emotions and i
thought for years people would ask me
about this stuff tom and i thought this
is ridiculous first of all i'm a vision
scientist and i work on stress it's like
there's no way and then i really ate my
words because four papers two inhumans
two in mice and then a fifth paper
published in nature which is kind of our
super bowl of scientific publishing
showed that these lateralized eye
movements quiet the amygdala they
actually suppress activation of this
threat detection center in the amygdala
and why would that be true ah so this is
really where it gets cool turns out
because of when the way that we view the
visual world when we move through space
when our head moves or when we walk and
things flow past us that these
lateralized eye movements
are what happens when you move forward
in space when you're walking when you're
moving forward towards something and
that suppresses
activation of the amygdala now you say
why well okay so then 2018
my laboratory did an experiment there's
actually a graduate student in my
laboratory where we're looking at fear
in this case we're looking at fear to
big looming objects that either trigger
freezing or running and hiding there's a
brain area that's in your brain and
migraine that mice also have that
triggers a third option not run and hide
not freeze but forward confrontation
this is the no i'm going to fight i'm
going to move forward in the face of
diversity this is the growth mindset i'm
going to lean into friction and it turns
out that this circuit is linked to the
dopamine reward pathway when we move
forward in the face of a threat and
obviously we want to do this in healthy
adaptive ways
we suppress activity of the amygdala
through physical action of moving
forward and there's a signal sent to the
areas of the brain that control dopamine
reward
those reward centers then trigger the
release of dopamine to reward forward
effort in the face of stress or threat
so when you hear about people saying
look take some physical action when
you're feeling exhausted take some
forward physical action when you're
feeling overwhelmed by this traumatic
experience now that could be in the form
of a walk in the now this therapist she
figured out with emdr because you can't
take people walking around for therapy
sessions she figured out that these
lateralized eye movements are what
trigger suppression of the amygdala and
it makes perfect sense because the
amygdala this threat detection center in
our brain it doesn't connect to the
limbs so how does it know if you're
moving forward well because the eyes are
moving you have these reflexive eye
movements that move anytime you're
moving through space
so to make this a little more succinct
it's really forward movement action
pushing yourself across that threshold
not only rewards you but it suppresses
activity of the fear centers in the
brain and these are ancient hardwired
mechanisms these aren't hacks these are
things that mother nature installed in
us
so i love this more than you could
possibly imagine uh this is
so interesting
so i'm i'm a big fan of wellness and and
i think it's a great community but it
tends to run in absolutes and there and
there aren't a lot of operational
definitions as we say in science and i
what i love about your questions you're
asking for
really getting to the meat of things
asking for the operational definitions
one of the most dangerous ideas in
wellness and in popular psychology is
that your body hears every thought you
have what a terrible thing to put on
people you know what what what a
challenging thing i don't think people
should try and suppress their negative
thoughts i think there is great value
however to introducing positive thought
schemes now the reason is not because i
think it's just because i think so but
because there's actually a neurochemical
basis
for controlling stress and actually
making stress more tolerable and
extending one's ability to be in bouts
of effort and that relates to the
dopamine pathway
so the molecule dopamine is a reward
it's
released in the brain when you win a
game you you know close a deal you
someone like to love your life someone
likes you likes your photo the great
love of your life you complete something
but
most of our dopamine release is not from
achieving goals it's actually released
when we are enroute to our goals we're
in pursuit of our goals and we think
we're on the right path is one
meditation very short five minutes where
for one breath
one breath you close your eyes and go
internal and you get behind and some
people call it the third eye right i'm
gonna get the the language wrong but we
all know what we're talking about you
get inside your breath
and then the second thing you do is you
focus on something at a short distance
there's a powerful system in your brain
when you focus both eyes on a single
point like a watchmaker making a watch
or you're reading that state is
accessing very specific channels in your
brain that are very different from the
one that when you close your eyes okay
and it's called a virgin's eye movement
when you put both your eyes on the same
thing and then the last one is the one
that we get a lot of here that feeling
awesome feeling when you go out to the
beach or you're on the top of a mountain
or you look at the horizon or you arrive
in new york city if you're me and you
just go oh my god and you're defocused
and that's when you're these ideas the
creativity
kind of spontaneously geysers up from
below but then you have to get back and
you need to get to work on something and
so the what's been very powerful and
we're going to put we're putting
patients through this or
subjects in brain imaging is this way of
accessing all these different brain
states is really about accessing
different notions of space and time
trying to get access to your whole brain
it's a short meditation i recommend just
one breath at each of these kind of
stations
in your mind
up close and focusing on your hand and
out and i'll repeat that a few times
during my morning maybe once or twice
during the day it's quick and we're
getting remarkable feedback
from the people that are doing this
about the kind of state that it puts
them in both engaged and present with
the bigger picture and in the end it's
all about the bigger picture right
because it's about not just what you do
with your life but how you're going to
create good in the world so one of the
reasons why breathing is such a powerful
tool for shifting one's state
is that a it's always available
for voluntary control it's just right
there you can i can decide right now to
do three inhales
or i can just go back to breathing
reflexively i just do that at any moment
so the the neural
arc you know real estate which is in the
brainstem that controls breathing
is in a unique position because it's at
the kind of boundary between conscious
control and unconscious control i can't
do that for my digestion i can't do that
for
most most everything that happens
internally the other thing is that
breathing controls
our level of alertness very dramatically
so the faster you breathe generally the
more alert you are the slower you
breathe the more calm you're going to be
the faster you breathe meaning shorter
quick breaths or
either way
so um so we're just to take a brief um
adventure through the the neuroscience
of breathing and how it relates to brain
states and and there's some fun tools in
here so forgive me for this tangent but
you have two brain areas that are
responsible for breathing one is called
for the aficionados the pre-butt singer
complex it was discovered by jack
feldman at ucla it's named after a
bottle of wine so now you people won't
forget it and
it controls rhythmic breathing
so inhale exhale inhale exhale it's just
rhythmic breathing
there's another brain area that controls
breathing
which is near what's called the
parafacial nucleus which involves
breathing anytime there are double
inhales or double exhales or triple
inhales you say well why would you have
this second brain area for breathing
well turns out when you're speaking or
crying or coughing you need to
coordinate your breathing with your
speaking and that means sometimes you
need to take multiple inhales or
multiple exhales and this is all
happening very very fast you don't
notice but
there's a very important discovery that
was made a few years ago by jack's lab
and by a guy named mark krasnow at
stanford
who discovered there's a set of neurons
in your brain stem mind brainstem
everybody's brainstem and every animal
every mammal's brainstem it's a very
small number of neurons that controls a
specific pattern of breathing which are
called physiological size
so these are not just size where you go
and exhale
these are sides that involve doing two
inhales and then an extended exhale we
all do this you do this during sleep
anytime carbon dioxide levels in your
bloodstream get too high
in order to get more oxygen into your
system people also do this if they've
been crying or sobbing they'll do this
and then they'll exhale so what's
happening with these physiological sides
and why is this powerful so your lungs
are too big bags of air but they
actually are made up of a ton of little
sacks of air called the alveoli of the
lungs
when we are exercising or when we are
sleeping or anytime we're doing anything
these these little sacks of air
eventually start to collapse and what
happens is carbon dioxide builds up in
our system and we experience that as
stress we actually feel the impulse to
breathe because carbon dioxide levels
get too high there are neurons that
sense carbon dioxide and then
without realizing it you do a double
inhale
and then exhale typically the inhales
are done through the nose and the exhale
is done through the mouth so it looks
like
and why the second inhale well if you've
ever tried to blow up a balloon for a
kid at a kid's party or just blowing up
a balloon you sometimes blow into that
empty balloon
what do you do you do two in you do two
you go
and then it pops open so these double
inhales pop open the avioli of the lungs
they don't explode them but they pop
them open which
pulls carbon dioxide out of the
bloodstream
brings oxygen and then you offload
carbon dioxide so if you watch a dog
right before it takes a nap or something
it often will do these now what's cool
about these physiological size is
from work in our lab and that's still
ongoing i just want to say it's still
ongoing but work in other labs as well
double inhales followed by an extended
exhale are the fastest way that i'm
aware of to bring the mind and the body
into a more relaxed state really yeah it
lasts this way but if i'm stressed i'm
overwhelmed just do a
three or two two inhale through the nose
and then exhale slow through the middle
one to three of those repeated will
bring your level of autonomic arousal
down
basically to baseline i would hide in
the tower books section
uh in the evenings and i would read
everything about fitness psychology
anything i could i've always devoured
information my favorite book when i was
a kid was the encyclopedia or the
guinness book of worlds records so i was
like when i was a little kid i'd walk
around the aspen center for physics and
i would tell anyone i didn't even ask
them if they wanted to hear about like
the what's the world's smallest
eutherian mammal you know i would i
could tell you all these facts that were
kind of meaningless at the time but um
i've always been fascinated by the
inventory of different animals on the
planet and their different behaviors and
so
yeah voracious reader and still now
yeah i love i love information you know
the beliefs are attached to a set of
rewards
so
what now the dopamine system is
exceedingly powerful because dopamine
is
is a kind of a dumb molecule it has no
brain of its own it's just a it's just a
molecule right it's just a chemical but
when dopamine is released in our brain
we
first of all it tends to orient us
towards
goals in the outside environment it's
the it's the molecule not just a reward
but of motivation and when we release
dopamine we tend to see the world in
terms of external goals
and so you can imagine now if there's a
process built up inside us where our
thoughts
are causing
dopamine release and dopamine is shaping
what we see as rewards what we perceive
as rewards
that can be
wonderful or terrible depending on how
that's harnessed so let me understand
this
when we have
dopamine
uh triggered in our body
it's attached to
because it's attached to some type of
belief we're going to continue to say
this feels good that's right so let me
keep thinking this way and viewing the
world in this way because it's going to
keep making me feel good that's right
physically that's right wow even if it's
fact or not fact scientifically true or
not or harmful to other people or
harmful to yourself if it makes you feel
good you might stick to that belief
that's right so a good example with
dopamine is it with any time thinking
about science and neuroscience in
particular thinking at the extremes can
be kind of useful so people who are very
depressed who see no possibility in the
world
if you talk to a depressed person every
response they give is going to be but
it's not going to work out it doesn't
they are absolutely certain that things
are going to turn out bad and there's a
benefit
for having that belief they're
entrenched in it they may actually be
rewarding that somewhat although
typically depressed states have very low
dopamine
at the opposite extreme is mania when
people are in a manic phase dopamine is
very high we know this and they see
possibility everywhere and there's
certain things are going to work out
they they will spend money they don't
have they'll create relationships they
don't have time and energy for they will
overdo everything and so somewhere in
the middle is this healthy range where
we're con where we realize that how we
view the world is shaping the release of
these chemicals and i do believe this
happens when we have positive thoughts
we we get a lift if we if we can get a
lift from our positive thoughts
and then dopamine itself puts us in
relationship with the outside world such
that we view the outside world as having
more possibility that is going to put us
into forward momentum
they're good there are a lot of studies
to support that when dopamine is low we
tend to see very little possibility in
the world
and so a positive thought
triggers
forward movement potentially yes yeah so
positive thinking which a lot of people
say well that's just positive thinking
it doesn't work some people say be
positive think positive others say well
it doesn't work
but with science i'm hearing you say it
gives you a little bit of a lift
absolutely the the key with positive
thinking it is that it has to be
honest it it can't be i've already won
you know i don't have an olympic gold
medal if i could tell myself i'm going
to get one tomorrow but i just don't
have the skills so that's not going to
release dopamine in my system how do you
know it's honest if you're in a
depressed state and you don't believe
that
you are actually better off than where
you're at the key is to attach the so
one thing to understand is that dopamine
release in the brain is always
subjective
there's no experience that that says uh
that has unique domain over dopamine
release that will only allow dopamine
release so
if it's very subjective so if i say to
myself
i'm going to um get into the process of
doing something we have a new year
coming up so there'll be a lot of
resolutions soon
the
it's not a if you attach the dopamine
release to the process of effort or goal
setting itself you'll have more energy
to be an effort and then if you can
attach dopamine release to the belief
that you're at least heading in the
right direction you'll have more energy
to keep going in the right direction
people make the mistake of thinking
that
the
positive thought process should be
attached to the finish line
it's not about thinking you've already
won it's not about being delusional it's
about thinking that your training is
going to take you to the finish line and
so it's about moving that mental horizon
in more close
more closely and then triggering some
sort of positive internal representation
of what you're doing meaning thinking
positive and people this is usually
where i get stopped and people say wait
but it sounds so subjective tell me
exactly how to do it but here's the
thought
it's supposed to be subjective
this is this for you right yeah everyone
needs to figure out what allows them to
continue to be in forward momentum what
allows them to constrain the world of
possibilities
and to go after goals and how often to
self-reward
because
but the key is the self-worth because if
you start only pursuing external rewards
that's when you are no longer in control
of your dopamine system because you're
relying on actually something physically
happening in the physical world not
internal that's right and let's be
really really honest and burst the the
bubble that i feel like should have been
burst a long time ago which is yes
everybody including me it is possible
that you can do everything and still
fail no one wants to say that but the
way that you insure against that is to
attach reward to the effort process
because the dopamine molecule creates a
sense of certainty and you're not trying
to create certainty about the final
outcome you're trying to create
certainty only about the next outcome
that's enroute to the final outcome the
next action
you want to think about milestones yes
and so people set out with oh i'm gonna
i'm gonna write the great american novel
or i'm going to um you know get the ipo
and of course that's an important you
need to have a sense of what the finish
line would actually look like but the
more that one can attach this subjective
release of dopamine process to the
intermediate steps through positive
thinking and action positive thinking
and action
the the higher that probability goes
toward in science we say there's a
probability of zero to one the higher
that probability goes to one which is
certainty now
everyone knows in the back of their mind
that there is no absolute certainty when
i hear about you know athletes or
fighters i was certain i was going to
win we all know that there's a point
zero zero zero zero doubt
in everybody right point zero zero
whatever that is now for some people
they
might be able to push that number way
way out but
certainty about outcome is actually a
form of delusion
certainty about romania yeah that's
right that's right you see this in mania
and that's why people start engaging
their behavior
online this is going to happen that's
right the silver lining in this is that
when you create certainty about outcomes
you know you can control
you take over this neurobiological
system and you create almost certainty
that you will complete the process to
the end goal
perfectly understanding that pain and
pleasure in this really dynamic balance
can also help us which in the following
way
any pain that you feel the longer day
the less sleep the kind of agony that
things aren't working that power outlet
doesn't work or the internet is slow
whatever it is the amount of pleasure
that you will
eventually experience
is directly relation related excuse me
to how much pain you experience so we
know this from actually what nowadays
would be considered quite barbaric and
unethical experiments where they would
give people electrical shocks
and they would measure their response
and then they'd say we're going to
increase it we're going to increase it
eventually they get to the point where a
slight
shock that was previously very painful
actually evokes a sense of pleasure
now you couldn't do these experiments
anymore these are not the experiments i
do in my lab
and these are older experiments
but
for instance uh and this has been
discussed in scientific research papers
uh giving somebody a like a 10 minute
ice bath for instance or even a
three-minute ice bath or a one-minute
ice bath it's quite painful but there
was a study from the university of
prague the european journal of
physiology showed that after a painful
ice bath stimulus
the amount of dopamine released goes up
for two and a half hours to 250 above
baseline and that's not because the ice
bath
itself evokes dopamine release a lot of
people think oh cold water evokes
dopamine release no pain evokes dopamine
release after the pain is over yesterday
i tweaked my back because i do this
stupid thing every few years the same
stupid thing and it's really painful and
then you just remember all the ways in
which you can't move around i was like
standing up this way i'm like ah and
just walking is so painful as the pain
has started to dissipate you get a
little bit of a high right you get a
little bit of a euphoria that's dopamine
because of the the degree of pain you
experience previously predicts how much
pleasure so when you start a company
down in the dregs and you're shoveling
again
that's beautiful because that means that
the win that you achieve
is going to be as good or greater than
the one you had previously in your case
with quest and so we go back to this
example the person that's not motivated
that can't get off the couch that
doesn't want to do anything well this is
the problem we remember the rad
experiment they are effectively the rat
with no dopamine but they can still
achieve
some sense of pleasure by consuming
excess calories by consuming social
media and look i'm not judging i do this
stuff too right scrolling social media
if you've ever scrolled social media and
you're like i don't even know why i'm
doing this it doesn't really feel that
good
and i can remember a time where you'd
see something that's just so cool or you
see something online i remember this
when ted talks first came out i was like
this is amazing these are some at least
some of them are really smart people
sharing really cool insights and then
now that they're like a gazillion
ted talks i remember spending a winter
in my office at when i was a junior
professor cleaning my office finally
and binging ted talks in the background
thinking this is a good use of my time
pretty soon they all sucked to me i was
like this isn't good so what you need to
do is stop watching ted talks for a
while
wait and then they become interesting
again and that's this pain pleasure
balance and so for people that aren't
feeling motivated the problem is they're
not motivated but they're getting just
enough or excess sustenance so they're
getting the little mild hits of opioid
it becomes an opioid system and if you
think about the opioid drugs as opposed
to dopamine dopaminergic drugs
dopaminergic drugs make people rabid for
everything you know drugs of abuse like
cocaine amphetamine make people
incredibly outward directed or they
hardly notice anything except what they
want more of more more more it's very
it's bad
because those drugs trigger so much
dopamine release that they become the
reward it's very circular the only the
drug can give that much dopamine nothing
they could pursue would give them as
much dopamine as the drug itself
so there's that and then there's the
kind of opioid like effects
of constantly indulging oneself with
social media or with video games or with
with food or with anything to the point
where it no longer evokes the motivation
and craving and this is really the new
evolution of the understanding of
dopamine in neuroscience which is that
dopamine itself is not the reward it's
the build up to the reward and the
reward has more of a kind of opioid
bliss-like property which itself is not
bad if it's endogenous released from
within but when we can just sit there
like the like the rat with no dopamine
gorging ourselves with pleasures so to
speak what you end up with is somebody
that feels really unmotivated
and those pleasures no longer work to
tickle those feel-good circuits and so
there's no reason for them to go out and
pursue anything and that's a pretty dark
picture so the the keys are
to pursue rewards but understand that
the pursuit is actually the reward if
you want to have repeated
wins okay you the celebration has to be
less than the pursuit and that's hard
for some people to do
they you know they it's got to be that
your celebration is slightly less
dopaminergic
it can be very reflective you can be in
gratitude those are other
neurotransmitter systems but you don't
want to be on that high as you celebrate
the wind
you want to be
trickling out your dopamine regularly
until you pursue things previously i
told you that it's great to foreshadow
failure that that's a great way to get
your system into a state of activation i
also told you that you want to set goals
that are challenging but possible and
again here i'm paraphrasing from the
work of emily balcetis i want to be very
clear
there are a few other things that one
can do in order to bias the likelihood
that you will succeed in trying to
achieve your goals first of all
limit your options
trying to pursue too many goals at once
can definitely be counterproductive now
i realize that life is complicated
we all have multiple goals that we're
trying to pursue but if we have
particular goals that are important to
us we have to be careful to not get
distracted by other goals and many
people run into this problem so setting
one or two or maybe three major goals
for a given year is going to be more
than enough for most people and is
actually going to be challenging for
most people of course we have daily
goals and monthly goals and yearly goals
but if we have big lofty goals we need
to be careful not to contaminate our
mental space and our visual space with
too many goals and why do i say visual
goals
what various department stores and
supermarkets have discovered
is that the
greater the number of things in our
visual attention the more that we can
draw our attention and our goals off a
line of pursuit what does that mean well
let's think about in the practical
context this has actually been done big
department stores have figured out that
if they stock their shelves chalk a
block with many many options of food or
clothing items or objects or anything
like that people simply buy more stuff
people are very prone to
orienting their attention to whatever is
in front of them you put a lot of stuff
in front of them their attention drifts
you put fewer things in front of them
their attention is more narrow in a
later episode we'll talk about designing
a workspace that's optimized on the
basis of this it doesn't mean being in a
room with nothing except just your desk
and a computer doesn't have to be that
sparse but visual sparseness actually
can
help us orient our focus and our
behavior when we have a lot of things in
our visual environment or a lot of
things in our cognitive environment it's
the same thing and so if you're going to
try and pursue a fitness goal a
relationship goal an academic goal and a
long-term life financial goal all at
once that's four things and you're going
to have to come up with systems that
allow you to isolate those goals in a
very rigid way if you want to learn and
change your brain as an adult there has
to be a high level of focus and
engagement
there's absolutely no way around this
because so focus
and intensity and that kind of the the
goggins phenotype right i think gog is
now a noun a verb and a pronoun right
it's like it's amazing so if you're
going to goggins this process we need to
do is you need to regardless of how
agitated you feel you have to lean in
and focus extremely hard now the reason
for that is that there's a neurochemical
norepinephrine also called adrenaline
same thing
that's released in the brain and body
most people back off at that point
because they feel this agitation but we
have to remember that that
neuroadrenaline was designed to get us
into movement that's the purpose of
noradrenaline to take us out of
stillness and into movement and then the
other thing we have to do is we have to
take that elevated level of alertness
and we have to focus it and there's a
second neuromodulator called
acetylcholine
which is secreted from this little
structure in the base of the forebrain
when we visually focus on something or
in the case of maybe if you're doing
auditory learning when you focus with
your auditory attention so there is
something called adrenal insufficiency
syndrome which is a real medical
phenomenon where the adrenals are
incapable of making these cortisol and
adrenal hormones but the the truth is
that you have enough adrenaline and
cortisol in your body to last two
lifetimes and 25 famines i mean we were
built with a lot of robustness right
this explains you know that you know the
david goggins of the world they they you
know we we all do have that greater
capacity that people talk about the
stress is very misunderstood because
people think of stress as this ancient
carryover that's very unfortunate it
kind of gets lumped with depression like
oh this is just a
flaw in our design or something but
actually stress is wonderful it actually
activates our immune system so
anytime you liberate adrenaline into
your bloodstream you also protect
yourself against infection of bacteria
and viruses because if you think about
if we had to gather food and we didn't
have it and we had to then pack up and
you know migrate long distances you
can't afford to get sick and this is why
people who work work work and then rest
they usually get sick when they finally
stop and rest yeah it's like the post
finals phenomenon in university or after
the season for a game or the caretaker
thing where you're taking care of
somebody who's ill and you're just
work work work or taking care of young
children and then you finally stop to
rest you go on vacation and you get
slammed with with what is that because
you're being in your comfort zone now or
you're just because stress turned off
and adrenaline
and so that these the stress response
recruits the immune
organs of the body to release killer t
cells in fact wim hof breathing i know
you're familiar with whim
of doing 20 or 30 deep inhales and
exhales
and also combined with some breath hold
type work exhale hold inhale hold is
known to stimulate adrenaline release
and the one of the better papers that's
out there scientific peer-reviewed
papers is a study published in the
pristine national academy of sciences
where they brought in two groups
one group
did wim hof breathing
the other group did just mindful
meditation both groups were injected
with e coli
right crazy right crazy it's crazy the
meditators got fever diarrhea and and um
and vomiting and the people who did wim
hof
either didn't get it or got it to a much
lesser extent sluggish but that's right
they didn't right this is not an
experiment to do at home isn't this
crazy but it makes perfect sense because
it inc that breathing simulates a stress
response it stimulates cortisol and
adrenaline which signals protects the
body right which signals to the thymus
the spleen and the other you know the
the the nodes of the immune system to
liberate killer cells and so when that
bacteria comes in
the system is ready for it
your body is defending against viruses
that's right disease that's right
essentially
when you create a routine of healthy
stress that's right and and we can talk
about we definitely want to
you don't want stress on all the time
sleep is really important etc but that
stress response combats
infection because it recruits immune
cells so everything that happens to you
your entire experience i don't care what
anyone says i don't care what alignment
the earth is in
everything is happening because your
brain has these three jobs and all of
your experience is filtered through that
thing in your head that pile of cells
that's arranged in a very specific way
that we're still trying to understand
called your brain
just like we could be talking about the
heart whose job is to pump blood so i
want to describe just how the brain
works in three basic ways two of which
you've heard about before we all heard
the lizard brain the thing that freaks
you out when you think there's someone
standing in the corner and they turn on
the light there's nobody or if you were
to come up on a car wreck and all of a
sudden your heart's pumping your brain
is very good at that stuff and that's
great that's why you're alive at this
moment it is an unerring unfailing
system keeping you alive your lizard
brain and it's generally designed to
keep you alive and to scare you from
doing things that would hurt you it's a
shame because i would have liked it to
be generally good at making me feel good
all the time but that's generally not
what it's good at and i'm stealing from
the great tony robbins who says you know
there's paved roads to fear and misery
and cobblestone or dirt roads to
happiness and that's true at the level
of neuroanatomy you don't have a whole
lot of your brain devoted to happiness
you got a lot of your brain designed to
keep you safe so anxieties and fears
come about a lot easier you need to
combat those we're all getting better at
that thinking planning imagining and
doing is the other kind of end of the
spectrum i talked about that and then
there's the one that really counts right
which is this thing in the middle which
is the way that those things are
connected what do you think depends on
how you feel what you feel depends on
how you think we know this now this kind
of common knowledge
and it's these maps of your experience
it depends on what happened to you and
how you view the world and we know this
at a psychological level neuroscientists
sometimes talk like this they often
don't i'm in the minority but there's a
lot of neuroanatomy there's a lot of
powerful neuroscience to support this
what do i mean by your maps of
experience i mean what happened to you
shapes how you view the world and so
what's important is how you change how
you view the world if you want to go
forward beyond what would just how you
were programmed let's say
it was
me realizing i'm living in this squat
where i've got a pet ferret my
girlfriend's gone she broke up with me
she was smart enough to break up with me
you know
i'm getting in fights i'm working at a
bagel shop i'm barely making ends me and
at that point i just made the decision i
just said okay
look i'm i'm not gonna be a professional
athlete i think i'm pretty good at
memorizing things i think i have an
interest in people
i'm going to just
decide i just decided to do school i
decided that was that was the track so
like some people picked the military
because it's like if you you know what
to expect at least in terms of
the you know the passages that you're
going to go through and for me that was
school and so i hadn't decided to get
back in school i moved into a studio
apartment by myself i quit partying
completely i didn't go to parties i got
really serious about fitness so i just
started running and lifting weights
and i studied you went like henry
rollins style i did yeah i did it's a
lot of self-awareness you know i mean
people go into the military because on
some level i mean some people do because
there there's some yearning for for
having that structure imposed upon their
lives but you you constructed that
that kind of um structure for yourself
yeah i think i was really afraid
i think i was like you know and i and
these days you know because my lab
studies fear and i get into this whole
thing around mindsets and people always
ask me like is it better to do something
from a place of love or fear like it
depends and at that point fear was the
best motivator for me
and
i just basically work like crazy
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome to learn the 10
neuroscience hacks that can make you
unstoppable check the video right there
next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there we have the ability to actually
change the story all the time if you can
move the horizon to something you know
you can complete and you reward that
you essentially are where you were
before